from the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to executive order
2020-04 this public body is authorized
to meet electronically this is a public
hearing on bills referred to the
committee and scheduled in the house
account for today an executive session
will be held on any bill referred to
this committee
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporariously to
this meeting however in accordance with
the emergency order i am confirming that
all the members of the committee and
elected legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporariously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform and the
public has access to contemporaries
listen and if necessary participate in
the meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
notice this meeting complies with the
house rules and rsa 91-a anyone who has
a problem accessing the meeting should
call 271 3600 or email hcs
ledge.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled please note
that all votes that are taken during
this meeting shall be done by roll call
votes
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance with each member of
states their presence
please also state whether there's
anybody in the room with you during this
meeting which is required on the right
to know law all right keith
all right testing one two three
all right calling the role
representative hunt i'm here in uh and
by myself
patusik
i am here upstairs in my
room and my wife is downstairs and we'll
be going to curves in a little while
okay representative osborne
uh here in my dungeon in auburn uh no no
persons or creatures with me in the room
okay representative amman president
representative abramson
caroline
representative hamm
here alone
representative de palma
hello
president alone in this room
uh representative uh bartlett
here alone in this room
representative abel
uh home alone sounds like a movie
representative herbert
um
here uh alone in this room
representative van houghton
here alone
representative fargo
i'm here alone
representative weston
here alone in my office
representative bellew
here uh home and
alone in this room representative
burroughs
i'm here uh my husband is in the house
and there are a few workers in the house
as well
representative mcaleer
um i'm alone in this room my wife is in
the house and i just heard her fall
not really fall knock something over
and everyone's power is on so that's a
good thing
okay that's the rule uh 19 present
kevin mr chair
yes uh my power has gone off and on uh
our power went out last night so i if i
disappear it's uh that's probably it the
winds are pretty bad out here on the
seacoast uh the winds are bad everywhere
but yes
i certainly understand it and um well
this
hopefully it won't affect our executive
session when we're all supposed to be
seeing each other when we vote but we'll
see how this works out um the good news
is that we have today
we have tomorrow afternoon and then
theoretically we have next week which
obviously i would like to try to avoid
um scheduling it for but but we we do
have it if
the creek rises or the wind blows as it
may be okay i will open up the public
hearing on house bill 265
and we'll hear from representative rung
who's sitting in for representative
cushing remembers it wrong it feels like
it was about a year ago that we last saw
each other getting on an airplane jet
blue flight to puerto rico
that's right
actually virgin gorda for you i think
and it was virgin it was st john for me
but uh well it's nice to see you again
hopefully we'll see each other
flying together on to a sunny beach
somewhere
um thank you very much chairman hunt and
my esteemed colleagues for the of the
commerce committee i'm here um in place
of representative renee cushing to
introduce house bill 265
it's an important bill
because it
enables residents to have confidence
that when they buy bottled drinking
water in new hampshire that it meets all
of the standards set forth by the state
however you've heard all the testimony
on this already because this is
identical to house bill 335 which has
already gone through the public hearing
process
so i'm here to recommend that you
rule this bill inexpedient to legislate
so that we can move on with our business
thank you very much
uh thank you very much
um even though you asked for that we
still have to have a question because of
the full hearing okay
does anybody have any questions for
representative
thank you mr chairman
representative wrong
do you recall what the
house bill number was the last time we
saw this two years ago
oh
i don't even know where my car keys are
to be honest with you i'm sorry i i
don't remember the number i i did not
come as prepared as i normally would
have introducing a bill because um i i'm
i'm just a subbing in for representative
cushing so i'm sorry i don't that's okay
thank you very much you're welcome i i
keep trying to tell people all the time
i do not know bills by their numbers
i have last terms bill here is that what
you're looking for yes
and that's why we have ranking members
thank you
bartlett
it was house bill 1274. there you go
all right okay any other question for
her thank you very much uh
representative and uh hope you have a
good week uh on your committee thank you
very much well i don't have a committee
but i'll have a good week anyway thank
you
better
okay
uh
all right terms uh who else would like
to speak i have i do have three other
people
uh
who wanted to speak so
um
if they i don't know if they not want to
speak please raise your hand okay so i
got uh
james tonner and david muse
and michelle roberts if you three raise
your hands i can move you over
okay james toner is first so he gets
moved over first
promote to panelists
okay
all right good morning mr tonner toner
you have to unmute yourself
i'm sorry about that good morning
good morning
there we go um good morning chairman
hunt and members of committee i'm james
toner director of government relations
for the international bottle water
association uh just a couple of weeks
ago i was
testifying before you on house bill 335
and expressed concerns over the proposal
due to national uniformity and federal
preemption at that time i stated that
ibwa was neutral on the bill however
given further internal and member review
ibawa now opposes legislation for those
same reasons
we believe that attempts
to alter regulations for bottled water
testing and reporting requirements are
disruptive to national uniformity and
therefore are an impediment to
interstate commerce
just as a quick review epa addresses the
national regulation requirements for
public and drinking water fda handled
these for bottled water while epa allows
a more stringent uh contaminant levels
fda does not
this is demonstrated based upon state
oversight while the state has ultimate
oversight on drinking water within their
state
they do not have the same oversight for
water that is sourced outside of their
borders
both epa and fda regulates certain
contaminants based upon whether or not
they determine
there is a threat to human health
quite often that might mean not imposing
any regulation at all
in the comments i provided the committee
you can see how the fda addressed a
situation like this with regard to
uh based upon ibwa's request
to set a national soq for these
contaminants
although given that if
although given that epa has stated they
are in the process of planning for
rulemaking at this time neither agency
has seen an immediate need for sending
anything beyond a health advisory
should that change no matter what the
contaminant if epa and fda agree to set
limits ibwa will follow their lead in
several cases ibwa already has stricter
guidelines than those mandated by epa or
fda
two items i'd like to address that were
presented in the hearing on house bill
335 first while not all bottlers are
members of ibwa and therefore might not
comply with our code of practice for
most of our stricter or unique standards
that we have set
we have done so based upon testing of
bottled water we did not set lower limit
standards limits or standards on pfas
based upon what we were seeing in any
one given state but because we know that
bottled water manufacturers are not
seeing significant amounts of these
contaminants in their product
second proponents pointed to the one
instance where a company in
massachusetts provided water robot that
tested high for levels of pfas an
important point to cite is that several
other providers were also tested with
limited traces of pfas in their water
and that one provider faced consequences
and went out of business
it's for these reasons we requested the
committee not report this bill and allow
for national standards to best determine
contaminant man thank you and i'm happy
to answer any questions
do we have any questions
cnn we thank you very much oh well we're
getting
what was your testimony about
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question was your testimony about
house bill 265 or house bill 335
uh well it was for 265 today's bill but
we have to we testified a couple weeks
ago on 335 as well
okay thank you yes
okay any other questions seeing them we
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you have a good day uh re
representing me use sorry i should have
called you first
well well thank you very much mr
chairman um i uh testified in front of
the committee on hb uh 335 and i'm just
here to lend my voice my in support of
uh hb 265 as a co-sponsor as
representative rung said it is uh
identical uh to the previous bill and
and i think the the issues we face with
uh with this bill are identical um
i think there are a lot of communities
including mine in new hampshire that
have found themselves on the on the
wrong side of water contamination issues
and when that happens people turn to
bottled water and one of the things that
they they take for granted that maybe
they shouldn't take for granted
is that that water um
uh actually is less contaminated than
the water that they're trying to get
away
that they're being told not to drink
um this the idea that a situation uh
like the one that occurred with the
spring hill bottling company
a couple of years ago the idea that that
could occur in new hampshire uh is
extremely bothersome especially now that
we've updated our pfas standards
so to me
i think the the biggest issue here in
new hampshire
is that people actually have a way to
know
which
bottled water they're drinking has
actually met our state standards and
which which hasn't
um
one way to do that would be to simply
require that the bar that all bottled
water
uh be certified as having having passed
on new hampshire standards and that
would probably be the preferable way to
do it that that way uh nobody
would be in a position where they're
drinking water that might be potentially
contaminated
another way to do it might be to
require stores to
uh to simply put water that has been
tested and meets new
hampshire standards in one area of a
uh prominently labeled uh the display
itself uh and then to have another
uh section uh for water that that hasn't
met our standards
um to me the key thing is uh
is the the public
really does have a right to know um if
water like this is tested uh and and and
meets our standards um so i i urge you
uh to uh to pass one of these bills uh
and to retain uh the other
thank you
great uh representative abramson has a
question for you
thank you mr chairman
oops sorry thank you mr chair and thank
you for taking my question oh am i on
mute nope nope sorry still not used i'm
still not used to this
um
so you mentioned the uh
uh higher new hampshire standards uh had
you guys when you worked on this uh
worked this idea out originally
um
considered the idea of having like a a
label or a sticker or certification of
some kind that uh
bottled water manufacturers could put a
little new hampshire symbol on there if
they met certain higher standards
something they could do voluntarily that
would also
maybe have a little more selling value
for the end consumer
my understanding is that was an idea
that was kicked around by one of the
committees the original bill
uh that we looked at i think a couple of
years ago
would have required posting the the
actual uh test results on the on the
bottle itself which is a little bit
different you know it sounds like what
you were what you're talking about is
something that basically just says um
certified in compliance when you know
with new hampshire standards um
uh
to me that would be an acceptable idea
as well
again it's a matter of people knowing
what they're drinking
okay fair enough actually the you know
the follow-up of that question and i
guess the curse of being around as long
as i have or maybe it's a benefit is um
this is sort of like we had with the
bovine growth hormones
and the issue was mandating that uh
labeling of the product whether had
whether the farmers were using bovine
growth hormones
and the end result was that because
enough consumers i guess cared or they
wanted to know that whether the farmers
were doing it or not that the
manufacturers put right on their little
sticker like you were saying sticker
that's what max said that
in my mind they started out with
stickers and then they would actually
put on the package and i think even
today you'll see on the package it says
you know no growth hormone so so why
wouldn't it make more sense that that
this legislation you know wouldn't need
as just being doubles up again would
need legislation if the consumers truly
wanted to know whether
you know pfats were in their water
wouldn't they wouldn't it make sense for
these markers the bottle markers to put
to say you know be fast free
mr cherry i think there's there is an
aspect of this where there are times
when people
just don't want to know um and and
probably
one of the one of those times is is when
their water is contaminated and they're
actually looking uh you know to bottled
water as some sort of a remedy you know
but but i do believe that there's
something to the idea that if we have uh
uh if we have some sort of a label on
the bottle then people can see that and
they understand what it means
um that could drive uh more demand for
for water that's actually been certified
you know to meet the standards
um
i'm just looking for something that will
kick this off because when i go to
market basket and when i go to
hannaford's i have no way of knowing if
any of the bottled water that i buy and
i do buy poland spring um
i have no way of knowing if that if that
water really you know complies with the
standards and it's something i think
that's always in the back of my mind but
you know i'm not one of the people who
was affected by the contamination at
pease i'm not one of the people who was
affected by cochlea and i think there's
a very real concern you know for people
who've already had
pfas exposure about potentially
adding anything to their bodies on top
of that
because as we've all heard in testimony
on all of the other pfas bills
pfas accumulates
your body actually doesn't have any good
way of getting rid of it
so
i think this is
sort of maybe
not a top of mind issue for people who
live outside areas that are contaminated
but it's very much a top of mind issue
for people who do
okay uh
representative everybody's had their
question first question okay
representative abramson is your hand
from yeah i was no i was trying to do a
a a bit of a follow-up um
if i might
sure
uh so my my thought was hope i guess you
can't see it but we have logos nh logos
and things like that maybe if there was
something where we
um
if we could do this with your bill if
you're not objecting to it
have some kind of logo or label that
bottlers would be allowed to to put on
if they met the higher new hampshire
standards
just as a voluntary thing that the
company could do and
also show that new hampshire cares about
the quality of our our bottled water
well i think this bill is all about
water meeting the standards and and
providing consumers with a way to know
about that i'm a i'm a co-sponsor this
is actually a representative cushing's
bill so i'm not sure what his take would
be on this but
but to me anything that moves us further
down the road of consumers being
informed about what they're drinking
would be a good thing
okay representative patusek
uh i have a question for uh mr toner if
he's still
uh about he's he's done he's so we're
all set
you can ask
my question okay could be to
representative muse
um
does
not all the water that is sold in the
state of new hampshire meet the national
standards
we don't know
i some of it does i know that there are
butlers like monadnock that um
that actually publish uh uh you know
their their results you know in terms of
in terms of some some of the others um
i'm i'm not 100 sure
thank you okay
uh and
finally uh michelle roberts from from
dhhs
good morning
good morning can you hear me okay yes we
can
thank you
good morning members of the committee my
name is michelle roberts and i'm the
administrator of the bureau of public
health protection within the new
hampshire department of health and human
services division of public health
services
similar to our testimony for hv 335 i'm
here today to provide you with some
background information on new
hampshire's regulations of bottled water
and i'm also available to answer any
questions that you may have pertaining
to these regulations
also with me here today is charles
metcalf he's the supervisor of new
hampshire's dairy sanitation and
beverage and bottled water programs
within the department of health and
human services
hb 265 proposes to require bottled water
to comply with the maximum contaminant
levels in new hampshire's safe drinking
water act
the food protection section within the
new hampshire department of health and
human services currently licenses and
inspects all in-state manufacturers of
bottled water and registers annually all
out-of-state manufacturers of bottled
water who distribute bottled water in
new hampshire
all finished bottled water products
regardless of state or country of origin
are required to meet the u.s food and
drug administration's standards of
quality for bottled water and these
standards are specified in
21 code of federal regulations 165
110b
in order for in order to align with new
hampshire's drinking water standards
rule making has been initiated by the
department to require bottled water
produced or distributed in new hampshire
to meet the maximum contaminant levels
for the four regulated pfas substances
and arsenic along with
the fda standards of quality
the department has reached out to
stakeholders to inform them of the
proposal revisions and our final
proposed rules are projected to be
before the new hampshire joint
legislative committee on administrative
rules in june of 2021
should the spill move forward the
department does have one suggestion to
add the following language to the
proposed bill to provide clarity that
these requirements will only apply to
bottled water offered for retail sale in
new hampshire the department made a
similar suggestion for hp 335.
this is the suggested language changes
um are on lines 26 and 27 of the
legislation as follows
so in line 26 the words we would propose
to strike the words for retail sale at
the very end of that line
and then in line 27 we would propose to
add in
for retail sale in new hampshire after
the word state
so the sentence that is in lines 26
through 29 of the legislation
would read and the sentence begins part
way through line 26 with the word all
so the sentence would now we propose
that the sentence would read all bottled
water
manufactured or bottled out of state
for retail sale in new hampshire shall
comply with the requirements specified
in departmental rules under rsa 143
colon 6 and maximum contaminate
contaminant levels established under rsa
485 and again this is similar
proposed
language we offered up in hb
335 as well
this concludes my testimony and i'm
happy to take any questions that you may
have and i said as i said earlier in my
talking points here is that i do have
charles metcalf that can help answer any
questions as well
is there any questions for miss roberts
okay i guess we're all set
thank you very much
thank you
um okay
now i i don't have my calendar in front
of me did we say we were going to start
our exec session at 9 30 or do we not
give any time
yeah at 9 15 i believe um i think it
says nine
you're right it's 9 15.
okay so we're good
all right
uh
so we'll close the public hearing on
house bill 265
and
we will open up our executive session
um so i am going through it as is listed
in the calendar which is numeric order
so first up is house bill 65 and
representative rungs bill
rachel's law
and representative petusek
seconded
by representative osborne moves to
retain rachel's law and representative
patusek would you like to speak to your
motion
thank you mr chairman uh i believe that
this is a work in progress
and there is more information
that uh
we need to
um
yeah
so i move that we retain this
for
more work
okay uh representative van halton
thank you mr chair um while i understand
that um many things are working progress
there are many immediacies that we have
to look at this is a bill that that
stems from the unnecessary death of a
young lady and probably has impacted
many many lives uh on that basis and and
on the basis of the need of the people
going forward i do believe that we
should not retain this bill that an
autopass recommendation would be much
fairer to our constituents and much
fairer to the health of american
constituents thank you
representative bartlett
thanks very much uh mr chair um i'm a
little curious
about representative batucci saying we
need more information i mean we've had
two years of this we passed it um
overwhelmingly last year we had lots of
testimony this year
and um i do think we want to pass this
okay representative fargo i just want to
reiterate what both of my colleagues
have said you know we did pass this last
term this is an important bill um
continuing to push it out is not helping
anyone i think that we need to move
forward we need to pass this bill
okay any more discussion on the motion
to retain house bill 65
seeing on the clerk will call the roll
representative patusik
yes
representative osborne
representative ammon yes
representative abramson
aye
representative ham
yes
representative de palma
representative greeson
yes
representative
johnson
yes
representative paul
sorry representative
representative terry yes
representative bartlett
no
representative abel
representative herbert
no
representative van houghton
no sorry
representative fargo no
representative weston
no
representative bellew no
representative burroughs
no
i'm representative mcaleer
and me
and lastly representative home
yes
okay that's ten to nine
okay motion passes
and that's uh because it's just being
retained there's no um
georgia minority report okay house bill
uh studying regulated animal groomers
um
representative greeson uh
by representative osborne
maine
house bill 92 is there
representative greeson you recognize to
speak to your motion
okay uh there were a lot of
uh statements a lot of anecdotes mostly
uh and mostly centered around one or two
examples
uh
and what we're looking at doing is maybe
amending this to make it a two-year
commission if i remember correctly
that wasn't a proposal to do it's mostly
an unregulated business
and so um
just trying to retain this to to make
sure that we are
actually obtaining what we're seeking to
accomplish with this type of bill uh
because it is such an unregulated
business if
just trying to go back and remember i've
got all my notes here but uh
trying to find what's relevant to it but
if we retain it we can at least make a
better bill out of it
right to you know a commission uh
and have it go for a couple of years
would probably make the most sense right
okay uh representative bartlett your
hand is up first
thanks very much uh mr chair um yes the
we also agree that this um looks like
there's a real need uh for more study on
this um and we would agree to a a
two-year commission would be a good idea
with
the various stakeholders to be
represented
so we would go along with retain
okay
representative abramson
i've also got to agree with
representative bart
bartlett and grayson um i wanted to go
obviously in a different direction
ultimately with the bill but i think
either way the retained motion i think
is the right way to go
great
uh seeing no more discussion on the
motion uh the clerk will call the role
on retaining house bill 92.
and that was moved by representative
greeson and seconded by representative
patusek is that correct
sure
yep
i said osborne but that's yeah the two
sec is good okay i'll i can change it
you're just trying to keep up with all
these forms here yeah i understand
all right motion is retained on house
bill 92 uh representative patusik yes
representative osborne yes
representative amman yes representative
abramson aye
representative
ham
yes
representative de palma
representative greeson yes
representative johnson yes
representative terry
yes
representative bartlett
representative abel
yes
representative herbert
representative van gaalton
yes
representative fargo yes
representative weston
yes
representative bill you
representative burroughs
yes
representative mclear
representative hunt
yes
okay that's 19-0
ocean passes
yay
and just um briefly mr chairman i want
to point out that we we have lost power
here
um at the lob and that's what has been
knocked out you know you don't see the
kitty room any more but luckily nobody's
in it so
thanks proceed and i just wanted to
you know so so far i'm in the office and
i still have power up here somehow but
there's trying to restore the room and
and if something should happen that
could be the explanation if but if you
know since you're a co-host you're
you're still carrying the meeting so
great what happens
amazing okay
uh all right next up is house bill 162.
the
spirits and farmers market uh
representative pettusek uh second in uh
representative osborne moves to uh
retain
house bill 162 and representative
petruck is recognized to speak to his
motion
thank you mr chairman um
house bill 162 permitting tastings by
liquor manufacturers at farmers markets
for distilled spirits
what it does is uh
amends the present build to include
distilled spirits on top of wine and
beer there is also uh
a couple of amendments one of which you
you already have one which has not uh
been submitted yet
and uh we know that there is another
bill coming over from the senate which
is virtually the same thing as this one
but it will not have the additional
amendment that i already have sitting in
my back pocket
it will be already amended it will
already come over amended with the
amendment that we have which is
uh
526h
which is the same one luigi's got but i
haven't in my back pocket which i will
be amending
uh when we come back to this uh later so
i move that we retain
uh because it's not done yet
okay
any more discussion on the retaining
motion
yes representative bartlett um thank you
mr chair um
yes i think that um we're anxious to see
um how the amended bill gets through the
senate um it's the same bill
um i think retain makes sense
okay
representative van houden
thank you mr chair um i am the author of
o526
the amendment to which representative
patusik
referred and i'm not sure
how that would be different in the
senate bill
so although
although i think this is fine as is and
i believe the amendment is just tweak
the language this was just a matter of
tweaking language rather than tweaking
the concept
um i will vote retain
um hoping that um the senate bill comes
over in fine form or that we get a
chance to amend it thank you
okay
all right have any no more discussion on
the retained motion um
the clerk will call the roll
okay retain on house bill 162.
representative patusik
yes
representative osborne
representative ammon yes
representative abramson
oh i'm sorry i was still on youth aye
representative ham
yes
representative de palma
representative greeson
yes
representative johnson
representative terry
yes
representative bartlett
representative abel
yes
representative herbert
yes oh no
yeah representative van halton
yes
representative fargo
representative weston
yes
representative bill you
representative burroughs
yes
representative mclean
representative hans yes
19-0
okay
um all those in favor uh
i'll get you guys retained right or i'm
sorry i've
lost my place okay okay so that's the
retain bills uh so um
next up is house bill 177 71
which is will will be
a real vote uh representative patusek uh
seconded by representative osborne uh
moves ought to pass
and representative patusek is recognized
to speak to his motion
thank you mr speaker it's it's unusual
that i get to speak on two bills
consecutively
house bill 171 relative to food in cigar
shops
this bill provides snacks
for those who are in cigar bars who are
smoking their cigars and perhaps
imbibing in
some type of beverage uh everyone i
believe agrees that if you're going to
imbibe in some kind of beverage it's
good to have something in your stomach
so this bill would provide that at uh no
additional cost
and uh does not allow sale which means
he's much pre-provided
uh free of charge
which works for me because i'm cheap
and uh i believe it's a good bill and uh
even the
liquor
administration agrees that it would be
good for
them and it's good for business and i'm
pro-small business so i
move that we
uh
otp
this bill
okay represent van ham
thank you mr chair
um yes this is a bill that came over
last year and that we supported it was
lost in the
covid
um
issues so i think that
what representative patuck said it's a
good idea to allow people that are going
to be drinking liquor to also have
food in their stomach there is no retail
sales for there's no charge for it so
um
i think it's um would be good to otp
okay
um
any more discussions
none
uh the clerk will call the role on ought
to pass on house bill 171.
representative patusik
yes
representative osborne
yes representative ammon yes
representative abramson
aye
representative ham
yes
representative de palma
representative greeson
yes
representative johnson
representative terry yes
representative bartlett
yes
representative gable
representative herbert
yes
representative van halthy
representative fargo yes
representative weston
yes
representative bellew
representative burroughs yes
representative mclear
yes and representative hans
yes
19-0
okay all those in favor placing house
bill 171 on the consent calendar please
say aye
aye
those opposed
so moved unanimously
okay
next up uh house bill 176.
relative to on-premise delivery
and um i i will move to uh retain
this this bill
uh second by representative patusek
um
the we again this is another senate bill
that's coming over it's hotly contested
in the senate and they're working on it
um i believe the the department has got
a resolution
um so rather than trying to amend this
bill um my fear is always said and that
something could get lost in the wash or
the coveted shuffle and so by retaining
it at least we can have it come
september and make sure it's
if there's a problem we can at least get
it passed in january so but i'm hoping
everything is going to go smoothly so we
won't really need this bill
uh representative bartlett
thanks mr chair and um i would concur
that um we will hope that um the bill
that is making its way through with um
some work
will meet our
expectations so retain makes sense
okay any more discussion on the motion
to retain house bill 176 seeing none the
clerk will call the roll
and that was uh
hunt in patusek hot temperatures
i'm almost there
see the committee's back up
yes
very restored
all right retain on house bill 176
representative patusik
yes
representative osborne yes
representative ammon yes representative
abramson
aye
representative pam
yes
representative de palma
representative johnson uh sorry greeson
yes
representative johnson
representative terry yes
representative bartlett yes
representative abel yes
representative herbert
yes
representative van halton
representative fargo yes
representative weston
yes
representative bell you
representative burroughs yes
representative mclean
yes representative hunt
yes
19-0
okay all those in favor of placing uh
this is retained
never mind never mind okay uh house bill
uh repealing moving company statute
representative johnson seconded by
representative patusik moves to retain
house bill 207 and representative
johnson is recognized to speak to her
motion
i just think this bill needs some work
it's
just it needs work
well clearly that
there was some issues whether we
actually really want to repeal it is
another story but there was definitely
some issues with the current statute
that probably cleaned up representative
fargo i hear you've been doing some
homework on this bill
um yeah i i
i don't think there's a whole lot to
work with here
i would like to see at ito this is
um
repealing this the reason we were here
is because we represent consumers and
this is a consumer protection bill
and our law and what it does is it
protects people from
moving companies charging them
you know taking their goods for hostage
changing prices um it
it protects people from um
companies that discriminate against
peoples or localities i mean i see the
importance of this bill and repealing it
to me i just don't feel good about that
and i think we should
itl but as you might remember there was
that thing about where they had to make
a statement about how they were worthy
to be driving on the state highways
don't you think we should get rid of
that
i don't see that it's a problem
okay
fair enough representative bartlett
um thank you mr chair i am looking at
the blue sheet however i mean i i agree
that the um
those who were testifying didn't do a
particularly good job in informing the
committee um with what the issues are
but i do think we need to keep looking
at it and we had seven in support
of of repealing but
um one that opposed it and i
i have a hard time
wanting to repeal it without knowing
more about it
um so i do understand the retain
part of it um
but i'm inclined to
to not support i mean to
not support this motion of i mean sorry
to not support
the retain i think i'd rather just
rather kill it but
that's sort of where i am
okay
okay uh representative
thank you mr chair i think it's obvious
from the previous testimony here and the
exec and for the testimony at the
hearing that there's just too much going
on in this bill we've not been able to
give it adequate time and i don't think
we can give it adequate time given the
number of bills that may are likely to
be retained
for the fall uh this bill probably needs
a total reworking and a total uh parsing
out of its individual parts therefore i
believe itl is the fairest thing to do
unless we can give it due and adequate
time in order to rectify something that
is inherently
flawed in many ways thank you
okay
okay so the motion is to retain
the clerk will call the role
207.
oh fans got it there
representative patousek
yes
representative osborne
representative ammon yes representative
abramson aye
representative ham yes
representative de palma
yes
representative greeson
representative johnson
yes
representative terry yes
representative bartlett no
representative abel
now
representative herbert
no
representative van haltman no
representative fargo no
representative weston
no
representative bellew
representative burroughs
no
representative mccleary
representative hunts
yes
that's ten to nine the motion passes
okay
all right next up is uh house bill 245
representative johnson seconded by
representative patusek moves to retain
house bill 245
and she is recognized to speak to her
motion
hi
so this one i think we need to work so
that we can try to include
the
um
we pay uh the pre-made food so people
can get that and have that included
in the total number and
maybe
you know i think that would be a lot
better we can actually get some revenue
out of it they can include those
pieces into it so i think we should
retain it to
try to make it work better for everybody
represent john do you mind turning your
computer down a little bit we just like
to see all of you
there you go thanks
okay uh representative fargo
um yeah i
i think we should i teal this bill i
i see
there's a value in small neighborhoods
for seniors and folks without cars to be
able to get groceries within their own
communities and um
i just even the liquor commission did
not see this as necessary and i i think
we we don't want to have a lot of
neighborhood liquor stores um
i just i don't see the value in this
bill at all and i i would i tell this so
i'm i'm gonna have to vote against the
retain
fair enough representative abramson
so this was my bill and it's it's
created to deal with the uh problem i
agree with the retained motion because
we had a lot of different members with
different opinions on what should be
done ultimately with the bill
and it's an
intended to deal with a pretty large
number of
convenience stores around the state
that have to
stock
what at least in seabrook are dusty cans
of spam and eight dollar boxes of
cheerios and condensed milk and when we
go to the shelves and you run your
finger along the top it's obvious that
this three thousand dollars in inventory
is not selling in some of these stores
and they tell us that that they almost
never sell any of this stuff and they
don't want to sell any of this stuff
it's just damned inconvenient to keep it
around so different members of the
committee
uh wanted to do different things so i
think that the retain motion is probably
uh appropriate
representative greeson
thank you mr chairman uh
the the emphasis or the the use of the
term convenience stores
i think is part of the problem that we
we're looking at here when you think of
a convenience store it's uh it's the the
7-eleven type stores uh but the stores
that this bill would affect are stores
where the emphasis
the the sales emphasis or the draw to
the store
is not
uh small food items it's actually
the alcohol the the cigarettes the
tobacco products whatever um and that
sort so if the food that is being sold
in those stores is something that's
that's required by law uh to be added to
the inventory of the store and so
um
the the the person who's going into the
store is really not there to buy food
the emphasis is not food it's just they
have to have food to get their license
the uh what's being talked about is
being uh
to tweak the bill uh and support for
retaining it to be able to add it to it
would just be a allow for food service
to be added to be included in that three
thousand dollars so that it is actually
sales and the added benefit of uh the
meals uh the meals tax that would get
applied to it which which otherwise
would not be because of their of regular
grocery sales so i think retaining it
allows us to
actually do something that would uh
again it's
this
the current the stores that are affected
by this are not food stores they're just
required to sell food with the alcohol
so this would allow them to be able to
actually sell something
representative burrows
yeah i would just argue that um spam and
dusty cheerios may not actually be
considered food particularly the spam
part and that uh i think gross of these
stores have uh have the ability to sell
to buy anything that will sell
and there's no reason for them to have
items on this on the shelves that nobody
will buy so for that reason um i i i'm
not going to support retaining
i did not see that going that way so
unfortunately spam is considered a
canned food much like tuna
so
but representative bilo
thank you mr chair um yeah i have the
definition of a convenience store here
which is a store this extended opening
hours in a convenient location stocking
limited range of household goods and
groceries
what i believe um
some representatives are talking about
are liquor stores
because if you want
to be able to just sell beer and wine
and that is you know what you're going
to be selling there um
that's a liquor store
so i am going to itl this bill
okay all right just so i guess the way i
perceive this situation is that i i
understand representable you're worried
about package stores that they're in
other states because when you say liquor
store in new hampshire it
something totally different obviously um
but no i think the uh the discussion
point was uh that um we have this three
thousand dollar food requirement and
we're uh and i and i believe uh i know
for a fact that the uh chief of enforcer
uh uh
he agreed uh with me when i said
wouldn't it make sense that food that
you could actually eat right then and
there
like a food service kind of type you
know
rooms and meals
wouldn't that actually better
to
fulfill the food requirement and he
agreed so that's for that reason
retaining it makes a lot of sense
representative bartlett
thanks very much mr chair
um i i
have to oppose this
this motion um i i just don't do not
think there's a a way to amend this um
and to spend more time on it with an
awful lot of bills are retaining
um and i'm i'm going to um oppose the
motion
fair enough
okay any more discussion on the motion
of uh retaining house bill 245
done the clerk will call the roll
representative patosik
yes
representative osborne
representative hammond yes
representative abramson
aye
representative ham
representative hamm yes yes
representative de palma yes
representative greeson
yes
representative johnson
yes representative terry
yes
representative bartlett no
representative abel
no
representative herbert
yes i like the idea of uh giving them
some flexibility and serving
foodie
representative van helton
then it's a restaurant
representative fargo no
representative weston
no
representative bell you
absolutely not
representative burroughs no
representative mcaleer yes
representative hunt
yes
okay the retained motion carries and uh
12 2 7.
okay next up is house bill 264
representative abramson second by
representative patusek moves to retain
multiple before representative abramson
is recognized to speak to his motion
did you say 274
who 64. oh 264. um
yeah i thought that that the need was to
retain this uh
disclaimer i'm a republican and we like
to save money and we like to shop around
um i thought that the idea
behind
this bill was
that you would go to a doctor's office
or a hospital or or or
any medical provider and when you're
when you're calling around you want to
get an estimate just like when you're
trying to do car work or or buy
insurance or anything else i thought i
felt that that was the idea that
representative mclean was was promoting
um i thought that that was uh
good but the sponsor admitted that there
may under kind of cross-examination that
there may be some issues with the
language of the bill
but that there wasn't anything
structurally wrong and that we may be
able to just clean up the language a bit
maybe get something good out of this
so that's why i thought it needed to be
retained
uh representative bartlett thank you mr
chair i don't know there's there's any
way that the testimony that we all heard
um
is going to
that you're going to be able to to
so-called clean up this bill um
there are so many different ways that
the um health care costs are figured
um there is no retail cost per say
uh whether it's medicare whether it's
medicaid whether it's private insurance
um i just don't think there's
there's
we can put the effort in
to make this fit everybody
um and that's what the law is supposed
to do
um i
i cannot support the retained
uh
okay did we just lose representative
palmer
yeah i think so
so i guess we have win win problem win
yeah it's blowing here that's for sure
employment he's in plymouth right he's
in plymouth i still have power
yeah
huh
okay uh representative fargo
um yeah i
listened to what paula minihan had to
say the feds passed the transparency
regulation
um in 2019 that's effective january 1st
that's going to solve a lot of this
um i just i don't see a need for this
bill there's too much work to make it
even a viable i i just i think there are
other bills that probably would warrant
the work
before this one so i would i can't i'd
like to i tell this one
okay representative burroughs
yes thank you um i was just gonna just
gonna add that most doctors um don't
have access to the information that
would be required
to fulfill this requirement most doctors
don't know the codes
that are used by insurance companies
they don't know the monetary value of
the code so for that reason i'm going to
vote itl
okay
uh representative bartlett
thank you i think um
representative mclaren is trying to get
your attention too but he didn't hit the
raise your hand button i can't find that
one oh it's um look on the bottom screen
look on the bottom and just touch the
bottom where this task bar is and there
should be a reactions and you can raise
your hand there but
anyway at any rate i i don't think this
bill is workable at all i i think that
uh it would take a clairvoyant to uh
actually come up with an answer that's
even close to an estimate i just don't
think it's workable
and i'll vote itl
representative berlin now you have a
question
thank you um mr chair in addition
paula minneham
testified that this wouldn't apply to
private doctor's office
tyler brennan came to us from the
insurance department there's already
um a place on the website that gives you
a rough idea of what costs are
from various hospitals or various
some service providers but to put the
work into this there's just i don't
believe there's any way
you're going to be able to to fashion a
bill
that is going to meet the the goal of of
the sponsor
so i i
i have to vote itl
representative abramson
uh one of the ideas that was brought up
at the hearing was that perhaps the
hospital or clinic or service provider
might just provide the information that
they have present at that time
um so but we would have to discuss that
and and and
question and challenge that and see is
is that beneficial or not or is that
necessary are there other ways to do it
and that's why retaining just makes more
sense
representative patusek
uh thank you mr chairman um
like representative abramson i believe
there is more information to be gotten
and i also agree that yes there are
standardized
type of
tables
available on the internet that would
give you a rough idea but i think if the
the
sponsor would come back with some more
information would make this a more
workable bill
thank you sir
i see that i see this as we have two
choices we can
give this a quick test now
or we can
let it die
uh
in the fall
and
so i am for ito
fair enough okay any more discussion on
the motion of retaining 264.
uh seeing none when you got you two uh
john and rich can you put your hands
down that'd be great
and the clip will call the roll
representative patusik
yes
representative osborne
representative ammon yes representative
abramson
aye
representative ham
yes
representative de palma yes
representative greeson
yes
representative johnson
representative terry yes
representative bartlett
no
representative
abel
no representative herbert
no
representative van halton
representative fargo now representative
weston no
representative bellew
no
representative burroughs now
representative mcaleer
l
representative hunt
yes
that's ten to nine
okay
moving on um
next i have on my list uh is actually
house bill 265 was technically not
on the
list for bills to be exact today
and it is normally not my personality to
ever kill a bill or
pass a bill on the same day we heard it
um i always thought that every bill
should get 24 hours of life however this
we have this a
different
situation because we have another bill
related to it so um
i guess uh uh
how the house the committee feels or
anybody has a problem for us taking up
this bill now
actually mr chairman it wasn't listed in
the calendar no it wasn't listen to
calendar but because we heard it today
oh you could okay you're right
so that you can just you list so many of
them i thought you
so this is so into in you know this
isn't what i would ever do but yeah
representative bartlett um thanks mr
chair um no i have spoken with the
sponsors on this and they understood our
position um and i'm i'm fine with with
executing it now
but for the record i would never do this
you know generally
we understand it's it will definitely
keep you on the record
my personality to do something like this
but okay uh representative abramson uh
seconded by
representative patusek
moves in expedient to legislate and
represent abramson is recognized to
speak to his motion
so
i like the idea of the bill but
we already have house bill 335 that were
that we're proposing to retain so
uh it's nothing personal but this is
exactly the same as uh 335 so
as the uh as the introducer suggested
uh first thing i moved that we itl this
bill and work on 335 instead
um just to be clear the the person who
introduced representative rung is a
co-sponsor
yes available
ammon yes representative abramson
aye
representative ham
yes representative de palma
yes
representative greeson
representative johnson
representative johnson representative
terry yes representative bartlett yes
representative abel
yes representative herbert
yes
representative van halton
representative fargo yes representative
weston yes
representative bell you
yes
representative burroughs
representative mcaleer
representative mcelroy
there oh he froze he froze
he's definitely frozen
representative hunt you can come back
let's try this um yeah yes
okay that's 18 to zero okay that's fine
[Music]
okay
uh
all right um next one we shouldn't have
to i think we're going to excuse me is
that going to be on consent all those in
favor of saying placing uh 265 on the
consent calendar please say aye
aye aye those opposed so moved
unanimously
okay
yeah
okay um
okay so let's take up the next one i
think we'll be all right house bill 299
representative patusek seconded by
representative bartlett moves out to
pass so
representative patusek is recognized to
speak to his motion
thank you mr chairman uh
plain and simply
this bill clarifies certain
responsibilities and
responsibilities of the insurance
department and was requested by the
insurance department
it has a melange of
pieces of information that fix clean up
update
a lot of uh the insurance laws
and i therefore move to
um otp
okay
in the other discussion on the motion
about to pass
all right saying none the clerk will
call the roll
just need one one second here
that was patoo6 i could find bartlett
yes
representative patusik
representative osborne
yes
representative ammon yes representative
abramson aye
representative hamm yes
representative de palma
yes
representative greeson
representative johnson
yes
representative terry yes
representative bartlett
yes
representative abel
representative herbert
yes
representative van houten
representative fargo yes representative
weston
yes
representative bill you
representative burroughs
i don't see her either
no it looks like she's gone too
drop them like floss
representative mcleary
yes
that's 17-0 mr j
all right all those in favor are placing
house bill 299 in the consent counter
please say aye
aye
that was supposed
to move unanimously
okay
uh i'm wondering if we should put some
kind of a disclaimer
about today and the weather
um i don't i don't know but i wouldn't
be surprised if i come up uh missing
soon it is the wind is blowing
so ferociously that i
i feel and and hear it unbelievably out
there
so i may i may lose electricity i'm not
sure
i just lost mine for a few minutes and
dropped out so i might okay you're back
yep
yeah
so
some of plymouth loses power and some
does not amazing i mean i'm sure that um
reps um mclear and burroughs are trying
to get back in
right as they can with even if it's just
by phone we can we can live with that
can't we mr chair
yeah that's the hard part
as long as we recognize their voice
and i would have to write down the phone
number just in case that happens i'm
going to have to look it up and write it
down because i won't have access to
the
computer anyway
does it violate house rules if we're not
on video yeah that's uh
we have to be on video we have to see
faces
uh representative osborne
uh yes we do have rules that we need to
follow uh however um would it be
appropriate to um
make a
gentle lady and gentleman's agreement
that if someone on one side is to drop
off someone on the other side will take
a walk
uh right well this uh the senate calls
this pairing
because of the 24 of them they would do
that if someone was unable to
participate
someone else would not participate
so
i don't know
how do you
i guess
i'm willing to do that if everyone else
is
i i think that would be a good
thing yeah because there's we have no
control over you know who it is it's
going to get dropped off it could happen
to any of us
otherwise what will happen is if the
vote goes awry
then tomorrow when we come back we're
going to have to go through a bunch of
reconsideration motions and that's not
going to be good for anybody
exactly
um okay representative abramson you had
your hand up i actually disagree with
that if that were to happen
um
you know i would honestly rather do
reconsideration but as far as the rules
are concerned rules of the house we're
no longer republicans and democrats and
if some i
i don't like doing the zoom uh meetings
at all i would rather meet in the lob
but i've already stated that issue um
earlier and
uh as as far as the house rules are
concerned if you're a member you're here
if you if if if somebody drops out um i
i think that we could do if they can
come back on later today we could just
do the reconsideration or the chair can
just hold the vote up until the end of
the day if it's really
you know if we lose too many members
okay so well that's represent terry go
ahead
thank you mr chair um
i'm okay with this as long as the
reasons
uh are spread on the minutes as to why
each member
did not participate for example if i
were to pair even though i'm present
somebody couldn't come back at me and
say you know why didn't you vote on that
bill
uh why did you take a walk on that bill
and i'm not going to remember so um can
you assure us that the reasons will be
spread on the
uh in the minutes of the meeting
indicating that somebody wasn't there
because their power was lost and
somebody else graciously dropped out in
order to pair
um
on the forum there's a not voting column
i could put
a note in that column but that's about
it there's we're really not taking
minutes other than the votes on this
well as long as it's recorded
right i but i have to tell you that i'm
the the worst panic in my mind is
that uh
that we send some bill out on the floor
with a 10-10 you know a nine-nine vote i
mean that i i hope i don't i've never
wanted my committees ever
to have a split decision go to the house
floor um but so i would probably do
everything possible to avoid that but
yet you're right we can reconsider
but then i am the chair so i can control
which bill we take up next uh and even
though i said i would take them in
numeric order
i certainly can be conscious of which
ones we take up and what order we take
them up in um and hope that uh these
other people
i i have texted both of them to see if
there's a way they can resume in in by
phone but um i haven't heard back from
either of them so i don't know
if they don't have phone either not
supposed to do by phone unfortunately so
i know
unless they have a smart smartphone
um and can we have smartphones
right so they have they have smartphones
they can log in with their phones
download the download the zoom app and
log in by the link
right right and
evidently doesn't take up a lot so okay
yeah okay um anita burroughs just wrote
back she they have lost power and she's
going to try to get in by phone he's
here
okay uh yeah representative there she is
it seems like we're wasting more time in
the interest of saving time so
do you think we should uh just do the
the bills that are uh you know are going
to be unanimous and uh save the other
ones till tomorrow since we're meeting
anyway
um we uh we can certainly certainly go
through that i i
i'm not sure how much we're going to be
unanimous but we'll but i i guess um if
you uh indulge me in talking
we're trying to exact some bills and the
lights will go on
[Laughter]
all right so the next up is a uh banking
department bill so i assume we uh it's
gonna be now the first one up is the the
vehicle uh repair bill
um
i
assume that's gonna be a split decision
so
no we're okay with that one no we're
okay with that one okay uh all right
well representative hands second by
representative patusek moves in
expanding to legislate and house bill
and representative ham is recognized to
speak to her motion
thank thank you mr speaker i recommend
an expedient to legislate on a house
bill 310 the vehicle repair bill
um
for a variety of reasons i
do not think there's sufficient evidence
that consumers
insurance companies
adjusters vehicle repair shops
auto dealers and all the parties
involved
can't come to
a
a reasonable decision
to accommodate a safe repair
to the vehicle to
pre-loss condition um taking advantage
of um
of manufactured parts um off market
parts or whatever it seems to be working
i don't think it's needed i don't think
there's enough uh evidence that unsafe
vehicles
are coming out of uh repair shops and or
consumers
are losing their ability to
negotiate
for
the uh repairs that they feel necessary
to their vehicle
okay representative bartlett thanks very
much mr chair um coming from the
insurance
side of things in in my career
i don't i have to oppose this bill i
don't believe that
um insurance companies are
authorizing unsafe repairs um we also on
our blue sheets had 14 opposed to this
bill with five in favor i'm just
bringing that up um that those that that
were interested
in the in the issue
and i just don't think that we heard
um
as i agree with representative ham i
don't believe that we heard testimony
that this
is an issue that is um coming up on a
regular basis
okay representative abramson
so i agree with the itl motion um
even though i recognize that there's a
problem the bill is trying to solve
um i felt that there were structural
issues with the way that the bill was
worked out and the way it would operate
i didn't think
i don't believe that we can solve
structural problems within the in the
committee we can deal with typos and
language issues and small small things
but i think that the the sponsors would
have to go back to the stakeholders and
come up with a different solution to the
problem
so that's why i didn't think that that
retaining would
i didn't think that we could fix the
problem internally
okay any more discussion on the motion
of anything speaking to legislate on
house bill 310 saying none
uh the clerk will call the roll
representative patusik yes
representative osborne yes
representative ammon yes
representative abrams
aye
representative ham
yes
representative de palma
representative greeson yes
representative johnson
yes
representative terry
representative bartlett
yes
representative abel
representative herbert yes
representative van haltman yes
representative fargo yes
representative weston yes
representative bell you
yes
representative burroughs
representative mcelroy
um mr chair i did get a representative
from representative hunt
yes sure uh yes
so
all those in favor of placing on the
consent calendar please say aye aye
aye that was opposed
so moved you madness so representative
bartlett did you get hold of
uh yes he has um he has no internet or
electricity he's tried to come in on the
phone and he wants to know if he can um
communicate that way and i told him it
had to be zoom
correct answer but unfortunately
okay um all right so uh
all right
we got another
easy one here okay house bill 312
uh
representative hunt seconded by
representative patusek uh
um ought to pass with an amendment we
have the amendment um is is that your
member connie is that the one we have
yes it's my amendment uh very briefly
the the amendment simply clears up a
grammatical issue there had been a
parallel construction throughout and one
area had not been fixed up uh it was
promulgated a bit ago
okay any discussion on the amendment
okay seeing none uh the clerk will call
the roll on not to pass on the amendment
so the motion is all to pass as amended
or
on the amendment
all right you give me one second i
wasn't expecting this
is this amendment zero zero nine three
amendment numbers again
zero zero nine three h
thank you
all right all to pass on zero zero nine
three h representative petusik uh this
is on the amendment and i vote yes
i'm confused you're voting yes on the
bill and the
amendment uh point of order mr chairman
what are we voting on
we're voting on the amendment right now
the amendment thank you
uh 93h
your vote is yes correct
it is yes
okay representative osborne
yes
representative ammon yes representative
abramson aye
representative ham
yes
representative de palma yes
representative
greeson
yes
representative johnson
representative terry yes
representative bartlett
yes representative abel
yes
representative herbert
representative van halton
yes
representative fargo
yes representative weston
yes
representative bell you
representative burroughs
yes
representative mclear
representative hunt yes
eighteen to zero okay
amendment passes eighteen to zip
uh
representative hunt seconded by
representative van houten uh moves out
to pass as amended
okay
one second please
that was the amendment
i can still hear those dings
yeah
i'd like to find out who designed these
forms
dings off
let me know when you're ready
before representative meckley is trying
so hard to get in but he can't as
amended can't get in on his phone
and moved by
who's it moved by again is it uh
same as before
uh
yes hunt in denham
say that again i i was i had my sound
muted because of the dings
hunt
and i was moved by hunt
and van halen and van halen same as the
amendment right
see this is where the old paper one was
just fine if you ask me yeah
diesel man
that's 312.
okay
all right here we go okay uh the
discussion on the motion is that this is
the banking department's uh bill and uh
i think we've
gone over it pretty well and so it's
ready to go ready to go there you go
all right so uh the the motion is ought
to pass
312.
i'll pass as amended
representative patusik yes
representative osborne
yes
representative ammon yes representative
abramson aye
representative
ham
yes
representative de palma yes
representative greeson yes
representative
johnson
yes
representative terry
representative bartlett
representative bartlett you're you're
muted
sorry i'm
oh you just i'm sorry
going back and forth with uh
representative mclare here yes
representative abel
yes
representative herbert
representative van houghton yes
representative fargo
yes
representative weston
yes representative bill you
yes
representative burroughs yes
representative hunts
yes
that's
excuse me 18-0
okay
zip all those in favor placing on the
consent calendar please say aye
aye
those opposed
tina your
hands up this yeah mr chair could we
just take like a five minute break
uh sure
thank you
okay so we'll go into recess till uh 10
35.
mr chairman
can you just tell me what that last vote
was i was interrupted over here and
missed the
bill number and motion and everything
18-0 uh ought to pass as amended hunt
and van helm oh just the you're still on
312. okay
i thought you i had missed a bill
thanks right
right
the amendment so we were delayed a
little bit
we just took a vote on as amended
so we're done with 312 right we're done
with 312 right okay
and hopefully
michael can get get up in the next five
minutes
um i sent um representative um burroughs
said that he could come over to her
house and he's only five minutes away
so i texted him that but he wrote back
otp 312.
so
i'm not sure he's getting my texts on a
timely
basis
need are you back up are you are you
yeah i'm up we did lose power so i'm on
as long as my i have two computers so i
should be okay i'll call chris to see if
he wants to come over okay
okay
yeah i'm texting as fast as i can and
keeping up with things
but maybe i'll go get a glass of tea
all right well i think we're doing
pretty good we're a third way through
so i think we're doing okay here
if we lose power here i'm down for the
count i don't even have cell reception
uh representative hunt
yes
um
i have a problem with representative
abramson's uh backdrop i think it's
offensive
you know
that that myself today was that i would
uh tell him that um
i think you know
we don't really have any rules about it
but
anything that's got words in it is
probably
inappropriate but i don't know i think
the shadow is pretty offensive i don't
know if you've seen the shadow but well
i guess i wasn't paying attention to the
shadow uh-huh it wasn't there the other
day it is today
so just i i just
was
yeah thank you
by the way chris is going to get on the
phone he doesn't want to come over
because i don't know he has a fire going
and he's concerned leaving it alone and
uh so he's got he said he's going to be
listening in
yeah but he can't vote
under the house i invited him over
that's all i can say
does he um so he tried to get in on his
smartphone he doesn't have power and he
does no internet i don't have power but
again i i have enough internet i think
to keep me going through the hearing on
your phone no i'm on the computer i got
back on my computer
oh it's charged my computer's fully
charged yeah so but how are you getting
your internet then
on your phone it's a heck out of me but
i don't have power but i mean you know
it's it's a wireless
uh yeah okay
you might be on your neighbors i don't
know no no they blocked me
he figured out i was using it they
blocked me
trying to get on to zoom on his
telephone
you should be able to
i i know i've done that before
yeah i i think he's a little technically
challenged
okay
this
thanks john for giving us just a few
minutes
all right
worked for me
okay
10 35 so i guess we're ready to start up
again
all right uh
is house bill 333
um
three thirty years
i get people should be i'm supposed to
see their face when we make the motion
or just when they vote
uh
so so those of you who are we can't see
your face you mind turning your camera
videos on so that we can
pick up
all right this is well now the next one
was abrasion so max are you there
hello
yeah just getting uh back
okay
all right
rich is up okay and hopefully connie
you're not too far away and you can hear
me all right perfect okay
all right uh representative abramson
represent uh seconded by representative
patusik
um
to retain house bill 333 and
representative abramson is recognized to
speak to his motion
uh so members uh disagreed
apparently disagreed based on the
questioning both during
the hearing and afterwards about where
he wanted to go
with the bill so it didn't look like it
was possible to come up with an
amendment before the executive session
uh and for that reason because this
touches on a lot of different issues
and requires a little bit more research
on
what federal issues are and what other
states are doing
i felt that we needed to retain this
bill
and and kind of reopen reopen that whole
can of words
okay representative fargo
um yeah i i
i think that there's some merit we need
to look closer at this i don't think
this bill is ready for prime time as it
stands but um
i
i i do think this is something that we
need to spend some time looking into
representative
sorry uh thank you uh mr chair uh i'm
going to um i look to over um itl this
bill because i think it is um
a bill for special uh interest groups
thank you
representative abel
yes i i agree um
i
don't uh understand this and without
medical advice as to what to uh
as to the
usefulness of this product um
i i could not vote for it so i i'm in
favor of itl
representative still muted
thank you mr chair um
representative bolio says that um this
is for special interest and i
i think that's who was testifying for us
i think that if we do retain this
i think we really
need dhhs to determine
where they stand on this um
they testified in the past because we
have this bill
i think it was two years or three years
ago
um where
it was changing the classification i
just think
i think we need an awful lot more
information if we're going to retain it
it's going to take
quite a lot of time
that's just my thoughts
okay
that's why we have subcommittees
all right representative van gaal
thank you uh very quickly i originally
had thought of retaining this bill as
well but as i just started up today i
was reminded of the fact that we don't
even know how to say the word kratom or
kratom i had to go to the google
uh to find out that it is kratom so if
it is that far out of our range of
understanding this i think i will be now
voting for itl thank you
i know what it's called
any other discussion on the motion to
retain
representative abramson
um i was just going to say really
quickly um i believe that the
the underlying intent of the bill if you
read it and and what the sponsor was
saying
is that he wanted to
the bill does essentially two things it
would prevent anyone from selling
adulterated kratom
um
which can be used as a tea
and he also wanted to
have state legislation that prevents it
from being sold to people under 18.
um it did it it certainly did open up
some issues
um but i felt that this is an issue with
whether you
oppose the idea of the bill or supported
the idea of the bill or wherever you
were
philosophically on
the use of kratom as a way of
an alternative for getting people off of
drug addiction
or depression that this is something
that we needed to study that there were
several issues in it that needed to be
studied so i felt that retain was the
most logical approach to dealing with it
representative burroughs
yes thank you i just was going to say
that given that this is a drug that the
fda is warning against and the other
agency that was brought up by the
gentleman from the i think was the
kratom institute was not a scientific
agency i'm going to vote to itl because
i think this drug is very concerning
okay so the pending motion is to retain
uh and
having no more hands up and i think
we're ready to vote so the clerk will
call the role on retaining house bill
representative patusik
yes
representative osborne yes
representative ammon yes representative
abramson
aye
representative ham
yes
yes representative de palma
representative greeson
yes representative johnson
yes
representative terry
representative bartlett
yes
representative abel
no
representative herbert
oh
representative van halton no
representative
fargo
yes
representative
weston
no
representative bill you
representative burroughs
no
representative mcaleer
representative hunts
yes
that is 12 to 6.
okay
all right next up
uh house bill 335 the other bottle bill
and representative abramson second by
representative patouzik moves to retain
helps bill
and recognized to speak to his motion
so i actually liked uh the idea of this
bill but again there were there were
some issues in how it's implemented um i
thought that retaining the bill to
consider the idea of something like uh
uh as we mentioned in the hearing on
that it's uh sister bill
that uh we
you know maybe as an option for for
bottlers that we allow them to put a
little special new hampshire logo on
there that says this meets the higher
new hampshire bottled water standards
and i thought that having a voluntary
program like that made sense because uh
as soon as we started uh subjecting the
bill to questions under its current form
uh what if the water is frozen is this
going to apply to bags of frozen ice
what if it's colored or flavored water
or salts or water
that there were a lot of issues we're
trying to do this as a mandate probably
wouldn't work and then there were some
federal issues also epa and fda issues
so i thought that
retaining it in order to consider some
type of optional program um and i
believe one of the co-sponsors on this
or its sister bill uh agreed that that
that might actually be beneficial
representative
bartlett thank you mr chair um
originally i was gonna otp this but um
whoops
um
but i i had the dhhs member come to me
late on friday afternoon asked me to put
in an amendment and it does kind of
muddy things up because of rules making
the dhhs has been working on
so um i will
and the amendment should have been
distributed to everybody late yesterday
afternoon
but i don't think we've had enough time
to um read it all so i will support the
retain
represent van gaal
thank you for chair um i do find some
confusing aspects to my casting a boat
at this moment but i think the bottom
line is that um just thinking back to my
high school biology classes and my other
biology classes about the importance of
water and the percentage of the body
that's made up of water and the
possibility that we are not supporting
the healthiest water supply for all of
our citizens i'm i'm
i'm leaning toward to pass and i will be
hopefully able to vote in that manner uh
water is just so critically important
thank you
okay any more discussion on the motion
to retain house bill 335
uh seeing none the clerk will call the
roll
okay
[Music]
um yes thank you mr chair um
representative bartlett can you speak to
the
what was in the amendment
well if the amendment was um referring
to rules making um and refers to a rsa
um let's see i have it
45. it was distributed to everybody but
i um i had
a number of amendments
not not just on this one that i was
reviewing and i didn't get all the way
through this one it came from um
abigail and i don't remember her last
name
um and i have not been able to look at
the rules making and i and i in my notes
i said i remember asking colleen smith
that when we had this bill before us
previously
um
they had also been saying that they were
working on the rules and that was
at least a year or possibly two years
ago so i'm kind of wondering where
they want the rules in
the bill
but they haven't been clear about
what the rule what dhs rules are
that they're working on and how long
it's going to take
so that's why there were too many
questions for me
well i i think that's even more reason
to move ahead with with the ought to
pass because if we keep waiting we'll
we'll never get clean water from people
so
i think i i would rather see this pass
i mean i have to say for my defense of
our subcommittee process i think that
when we do that we we are putting the he
on departments to
to get it straight and give us a good uh
good language that we understand and we
can get behind
okay
the clerk will call the role to retain
house bill 335
representative patusik
yes
representative osborne yes
representative ammon yes representative
abramson
[Music]
aye
representative ham yes
representative de palma
yes
representative greeson
representative johnson
yes
representative terry
representative bartlett yes
representative abel
no
representative herbert
oh this is not amended right this is
just the straight bill retain the bill
yep
yes
representative van haltman no
representative fargo no
representative
uh jesus
representative weston
yes
representative
l lu
no
representative
pearls
no
representative mcaleer
and representative hunt
yes
yeah that is 13 to 5.
okay
all right
next up house bill 336
the condo dispute board representative
tusek seconded by
i.t
i know people get phone calls on their
computer somebody's coming in
okay so the motion representative uh
patoo is accepted by representative
osborne moves in expanding to legislate
and representative patrick is recognized
to speak to his motion
uh thank you mr chairman
uh house bill 336 establishing a
condominium dispute resolution board
um
too many rules
too many people
it's limiting
uh it's not for condos time shares
homeowner associations
it just is too much of too much
and i move to itl because a i don't
believe it's needed
okay representative bartlett
thank you mr chair i have to say i
completely disagree with um
representative
batucci on this one um i think that we
have had year after year
of testimony from dozens of people
in the
thousands of condominiums that we have
in this state that there is definitely a
problem
they cannot resolve all of them through
their own boards many of them have
property managers
is this a perfect film maybe not but
i i feel like
we have got to be listening
to our constituents that are affected
so much that they need a resolution
board now it doesn't um i it's not meant
to include homeowners associations and
all these other things that that
complicated so it's not in there and i
don't think it belongs in there
um the mobile home resolution board has
been working very well for a number of
years and this is modeled after that
um i think that
it's a really needed bill for many
people who are in this state and i
cannot support an itl motion
okay representative van helton
thank you mr chair um
i think for what i have found some flaws
in the bill to mostly related to
language and i think that that that can
easily be worked out i i may be the only
one here that lives in a condominium and
i'm well aware of the kinds of disputes
that we have seen that could be resolved
far more efficiently and and and with
greater alacrity than what we have seen
uh what is important to me though is
that this parallels the manufactured
housing
um
bill uh housing ruling and uh that seems
to have met with some success and so if
we're following a model that has seen
some success i think it's due time to
give the condominium uh owners a chance
to resolve their differences without
having to go to court without um fights
within fights and things of that sort so
i would urge
uh that we kill the ito which is a poor
choice awards that we do not vote itl
and instead that we um vote autopass in
as an alternative motion thank you
i guess i i feel compelled to interject
here that this has nothing to do with
manufactured housing manufactured
housing is you contract with somebody to
put up a house for you
and and you haven't even moved into it
okay this this is a totally different
situation
you you have bought into this condo you
who knows how long you've lived in this
condo before you've had whether the
issues that you're having so i really
don't think it's a fair comparison
may i follow up please
absolutely i simply i i'm simply
referring to the manufactured housing uh
legislation as a process as a procedure
and not in any way shape or manner
trying to imply that they're comparable
i'm just saying that there is a
procedure that has worked for another
group
that seems to be amenable to to with
this group so
i hope i didn't misrepresent when i
spoke about that legislation it's just a
matter of procedure and process that i
see working um the products are very
different thank you
uh representative uh
bartlett
thank you mr chair um yeah i i'm
i'm a little curious it feels like
you're comparing something different now
not every
resolution um issue that comes before
the manufactured housing board has to do
with somebody who's contracted to
purchase a uh to to buy a house to be
built
these are
the manufactured housing
commission is for those who live in
manufactured housing not necessarily
because they had it built
condominiums aren't necessarily
on the resolution board wouldn't
necessarily be because they were having
a condominium built it's because they
live there so um
you know i i think we're comparing
apples and oranges here but
as representative van outen says
this is about process this is about
those who are not able to
come to a
resolution without going to court
with their own
board or other unit owners and it only
applies to unit owners
and i think it's a really important
process to offer the many many thousands
of condominium owners
that live in new hampshire
representative abramson
um we did we did actually discuss this
um
and um
it would certainly be nice to keep condo
disputes out of court
um 90 of them could be dispensed with
pretty uh quickly but i
the reason i'm going with the itl motion
is
um
you know some alternative like uh
you know long ago we used to use justice
of the peace or constable to handle
really small matters there were twenty
dollars or something that something was
a dispute that was too small even to go
to small claims court we used to be
handled by justice of the peace or
constable
so if if members wanted to go with a
bill like that i would be receptive to
that
but again that would be a complete
change from what's being proposed in the
bill
and
it would still leave open the the
possibility of people going to court i
like the idea of using
you know some intermediary step before
going to court just to keep court costs
down but
um i don't think that the
bill
takes us in the right direction i'm not
sure that the committee can fix
the bill to do that
representative herbert
i'm going to vote for i'm going to vote
for the itl i live in a condo and i'm on
a board of directors so uh
i'm i'm reluctant to have a third party
make the decision on my behalf
okay
uh any more discussion on the
motion uh for any speeding to legislate
see none the clerk will call the role
representative patousik
uh yes
representative
osborne yes
representative ammon yes representative
abramson aye
representative ham
yes
representative de palma
representative greeson
yes
representative johnson
representative terry yes
representative bartlett
no
representative abel
representative herbert
muted chris
yes sorry representative van halten
no
representative fargo
representative weston
no
representative bill you
representative burroughs
no
representative mcaleer
and representative hunt
yes
that is 1127.
okay and we'll leave that on the regular
calendar
right and um we need to think about
um who's going to write the reports the
minority report yeah
um
representative van houten do you want to
write the minority report
yes
okay
the minority motion will be itl correct
yes
you're right
because we just did itl
all right all right my mistake i'll
depress
[Music]
okay
pull a quick one on me
all right
um
uh next up is uh house bill 337
um representative johnson seconded by
representative patuck uh moves to retain
house bill 337
and
recognized to speak to his motion
hello hello
uh
so
there are some amendments that the
sponsor has reached out and said that
he'd like to work on um to fix some of
these issues because
if we pass it the way it's written it
would make these um
sports bars are these sorry cigar bar is
more of a rest
like a restaurant which then changes its
status so he wants to um work on
changing and making amendments so we i
would like to
retain it
so that we can work with him and
get it fixed
uh representative van halt
thank you mr chair
my preference is itl on this one
as the representative ahead of me
representative johnson stated it does
make it more of a restaurant and it's
kind of like saying we can take a duck
and make it into an elephant
by retaining it and waiting until
september
a duck is a duck and a restaurant is a
restaurant i support ito
okay representative bartlett thanks mr
chair i have to agree um i don't think
you can have half a restaurant
um and i i will
um vote to kill this
okay representing van gaal
you're all set okay
all right any other uh discussion on the
retaining motion
seeing none the clerk will call the role
representative
uh yes
representative osborne
yes
representative ammon yes representative
abramson aye
representative ham
yes
representative de palma
representative greeson yes
representative johnson
yes
representative terry
representative bartlett no
representative abel
no representative herbert
no
representative van haltman no
representative fargo no
representative
weston
no
representative value
representative burroughs
no
representative mcaleer
representative hunts
yes
that is 10 to eight
i'm just you know i did hear from um
representative mclear the winds are
blowing very hard he appreciated the
invitation by representative burroughs
to come over there but um
i i guess that um representative
mcaleer's
wife says no they're worried about trees
coming down
so um
um
happy wife happy life so there you go
he's sorry he's going to be continuing
to monitor it if power comes back on
he'll rejoin us
okay that's unfortunate
okay well it is what it is all right uh
moving right along then um so next up is
house bill 358
of all solar collectors on condos
uh representative terry seconded by
representative patusek moves in expedia
to legislate and represent terry is
recognized to speak to his motion
yes
thank you mr chairman
this bill represents
an unwarranted intrusion into the
affairs
of a voluntary association of
condominium owners for which there is no
compelling government interest at stake
to the contrary this bill's intent is to
effectively become a stakeholder
in an association in which it has no
membership
in so doing it seeks to require a
numerical basis upon which a particular
policy must be determined
the issue here is not solar
it is by whose authority shall a
condominium association govern itself
and by what rules government has no
legal basis for either voice or vote in
what is strictly an internal matter
thank you
okay uh representative
you're talking to yourself
you're still talking to yourself
one more time and talking to myself is
not that bad sometimes
um i i'm i'm really thinking about that
this might probably out of pass
as i look back at the legislation i
realize that the wording is not
anything that binds a condo association
it simply allows them to going forward
for new docks or new con or condo docks
that are altered
uh to to set the majority at 50 or more
this means that the condo owners will
still have their say as to whether the
solar should be there or not as i was
preparing for this over the last couple
of days
i received
um i believe was a facebook message from
um a member of a condo association just
north of may
freestanding condos and the woman not
realizing that this legislation was
coming up had shown a picture of how
solar would fit very nicely into her
free standing condo and estimates that
she would improve the value of her condo
from eighteen thousand to twenty five
thousand dollars
um this is an option for her it is her
style of condo but i do believe that
this kind of legislation would allow
that kind of an association to make that
decision is that something that they
want to put to a vote and it only sets
the value of the majority vote
so on behalf of my constituents and of
those people who have this style of a
condominium thing which
they have to vote on this is not an
automatic uh get out of jail
pass it does not automatically allow
them to have solar energy it does not
automatically change any condo documents
that currently exist and so i believe
that we should give those people who
live there the option and the right to
make decisions about their own homes
thank you
so just to make sure that normally for
anybody to change condo docks you need
more than you need like a two-thirds or
three-fifths or uh if it's titled it
could be eighty percent
and while that's true i think we're
setting a nice high bar here so that
this kind of legislation doesn't doesn't
go into effect without for that first
happening so i thank you for adding that
element to my support oh hi bars 50
that's a hybrid no no because what you
just said about the changing of the
condo docks it is that difficult to
change the condo docks going forward and
only after that happens can this
legislation trigger because the condo
docks either have to be brand new docks
where they have to be altered docs or
amended docs in order to have this
legislation pass
yeah see i i
interpreted this the language of this
bill is that regardless of what the docs
say about changing you know your
that it would only be a 50
but um but it does say that um
this shall apply to all condominium
instruments and bylaws adopted or
revised after the effective date of the
section and that's to that that is what
i'm referring to and again thank you for
helping me
represent bartlett
um
thank you mr chair
in reading the
the bill on this i mean i i think that
the intent um from the sponsors is
really that we have to make it easier
for
alternative energy to be an option
for condominium
unit owners
it's going to get more expensive to use
fossil fuels
and
we as a state certainly do not
interfere with any kind of a program
regarding solar
in here i mean if you go to
massachusetts you go down neighborhood
after neighborhood and they've all had
their solar
installations paid for
by the state and they have reduced their
their use of electricity dramatically
but condominium
unit owners don't have that option
where this applies only to
new
bylaws
people who buy a condo are going to know
ahead of time that this is that the
solar
um
installation is only going to be
available
when um
when they buy it
so i i'm in favor um of this of this
bill so i'm going to vote otp
representative herbert
thank you chair mr chair um
my take
away is i'm not against solar that's for
sure um but there are a lot of uh condo
associations that are substantial in
size
and uh
you know getting a a super majority vote
in order to
commit to putting solar
on those places is
uh i think
i'd like to keep it that way
i think the best way of solving the
solar problem
is to have
the cities and towns
put in their own solar installations and
that way everybody can have solar
electricity
i think i've heard about it
but it's not here not in our committee
okay any other discussion oh what do you
see
[Music]
some somebody pop it up there you go
representative fargo yes
um i'm
i feel that when you buy into a
condominium you know what you're getting
into and
i
while i think that things should change
i i think that 50 is not acceptable in
my estimation because there's a
financial obligation associated with
this for
for homeowners and i think the
two-thirds needs to stand i'm sorry
so i um
sorry
i'm afraid that i'm gonna vote to itl
list
okay
anybody any other discussion on the
motion of any expedient to legislate on
house bill 358 so none
will call the roll
representative patusik
uh yes
representative osborne
yes
representative amman yes representative
abramson
aye
representative ham
yes
representative de palma
representative greeson
yes
representative johnson
representative terry yes
representative bartlett
no
sorry representative abel
representative herbert
yes
representative van halton
no
representative
fargo
yes
representative weston
no
representative bellew
representative burroughs
no
representative mclear
representative hunt
yes
that is 12 to 6.
now on the regular calendar
day for commerce
okay
mr chairman uh did we did we skip over
the ambulance bill for any reason or
we had already executed that i thought
did we
oh we already did that one okay
yes there could be a minority report on
the condos
um representative hootenhauten you do
want to think about that one okay the
other you're becoming
a new um representative williams
thank you very much but yes i will do
the minority report
okay and the motion will be all to pass
yes
okay
no yeah that's minority motion
okay house bill 403
um
growlers of representative greeson uh
by representative
who's uh inexpedient to legislation okay
i'm sorry
all right
you're you're live bonnie
okay
i just for your information the wind was
blowing so hard it blew my front door
open
and so i make i yeah seriously it just
uh blew it open so i may come up missing
here i'm not sure representative mclear
just sent a picture of a tree that just
missed his wife's car
oh my god they were they're serious
he's not leaving the house
i'm sorry about the
inquiry that wasn't i was i was just um
shocked as to what was going on i'm
sorry about the inquiry about the
ambulance bill
no problem
uh uh so uh
right now representing griezmann is
going to speak to the motion that needs
to be legislated on this rally yeah so
uh
so house bill 403 relative to the sale
of alcoholic beverages and refillable
containers uh actually the sponsor of
the bill representative prout has
actually uh determined itself it is
inexpedient to legislate and it's
requested that we uh not pass this bill
as it is written so
kind of makes it simple for us as his
recommendation
representative abramson
so i was going to vote itl except i was
just contacted
by someone who believes that the bill is
still necessary so i
responded to his email i haven't gotten
a response back from him um if we itl uh
if it does turn out to be necessary and
we itl a bill
um unfortunately that would mean that we
couldn't bring the bill back up again
next year
um
it's a very simple um issue of just a
a kind of a repeal so there's no way you
can kind of work around that
that restriction
um and of course the issue is very
popular on citizens count i think it was
uh
unanimous uh support for
for
for bringing growlers with you um so for
that reason i would prefer to simply
retain the bill just in case um the
issues are not uh um
uh resolved
yeah well i i mean representative prout
said to me was that the fact that we've
been
youtubed the public hearing and having
uh
aiden moore the
attorney state clearly that
the law was not necessary
he felt it was good enough for him and
uh because he's got it on tape and we
can all see it on youtube
representative bartlett
thank you mr chair um
i
this is one that i can't support um
i i really feel we should i tell this
one i think that um the cleaning and the
labeling are important and emotion
i'm sorry
pending motions ito
oh good sorry i was texting with
uh with uh representative mclair again
never mind
okay
okay is the motion clear for everyone
the clerk will call the roll
phoenix being to legislate
representative patusik yes
representative osborne yes
representative ammon yes representative
abramson
no
representative ham
yes
representative de palma
representative greeson
yes
representative johnson
representative terry yes
representative bartlett
yes
representative abel
representative herbert
yes
representative van halten
representative fargo yes
representative weston
yes
representative bell you
representative burroughs
yes
representative mclear
representative hunt
yes
okay
well all those of you are placing uh
403 on the consent calendar please say
aye
those opposed
the move unanimously
okay
uh
next up house bill 416 home distilling
representatives secondly
use uh to retain
416. and representative is recognized to
speak to his motion
okay thank you mr chair uh i moved to
retain house bill 416
i'm one of the co-sponsors uh listed
i believe the bill is good intentions
but it needs some more work
the language could be a little clearer
it is included in
the uh
the rsa
v-5 which talks about
production of beer and wine for family
use
it used to be illegal at the federal
level
to
make your own wine or beer
for your home consumption
and it took people at the state level or
you know within states
to make that practice popular
and the federal government eventually
follows the lead of its citizens
i remember as a kid my grandfather would
make his own he'd grow his own grapes
and make his own wine in the basement
and i i couldn't tell you if he was
doing it before the prohibition ended
but i remember him being happy about the
prohibition ending
uh this would add
distillation of home liquor
uh not in excess of
200 gallons
if there's more than if there's two or
more people in the household per year
or 100 gallons
if there is only one person in the
household
and it's only for household use not for
resale
home distillation
uh
the technology for home distillation
is uh similar now to
remember when bread makers first came
out where you could put the ingredients
in a machine
set a timer and push a button
and out i would come a few hours later
a warm loaf of bread
well home distillation uh technology has
uh gotten very similar those products
are available in europe
um
for example
uh that that's one way that people may
do home distillation at home i think the
uh the the bill
needs a little work so i'd move to
retain
thank you mr chair i i definitely think
this needs work um we've had this kind
of issue around for a bit and have never
come to a place in which we passed it um
i don't know i will not disagree with
representative ammon but i i have heard
horror stories about home distillation
and and dangers that have come from that
uh and so that is a concern for me
i realize it's a narrow focus right now
with the homeowner the home distillation
going on here but it does seem as though
it it um it has the potential and i
don't want to be um too direct about
this but it does have the potential to
open the door to
um back dooring our liquor commission
backdooring uh a backbone of our of our
economy here in new hampshire
and so for a variety of reasons um i i
believe that an itl
emotion
would hopefully be brought to bear after
we defeat the retain thank you
okay
representative bartlett
thank you mr chair um i'm i'm much more
worried about uh
poisonous the poisoning i'm worried that
there's no ability to determine what you
know what's in the product i'm much more
worried about
um the fact that 140-150 proof is
obtainable
i'm much more worried about there's no
testing and no training for
homeowners to be doing this on their own
um
there's no monitoring um how
there's there's just nothing around this
this is not making bread you are not
gonna die
if you haven't put in all the
ingredients or let the bread maker work
it work hard enough on this
distilling liquor is a very different
process
um and i do not i i cannot support this
bill not the retain not not the
distilling of home liquor
okay representative bilo
thank you mr chair um i am going to be
i do not want to vote to retain it i
would like to vote to itl it
i have a problem with the word hobby
um
for four years um i was on environment
and agriculture and
we were we often
discussed hobby breeders now hobby
breeders sell their dogs and cats and so
i have a problem with hobby because i
think eventually they'll be um sales so
i am going to i would like to itl this
bill thank you
sales would they definitely
they would have to be licensed and
regulated
federal
penn state
uh representative abramson
i was just doing some research on
article 5 of amending the constitution
and the one
article or the one
constitutional amendment that was passed
by state ratifying conventions was
ending alcohol prohibition and reading
the debate from other states
was very enlightening about the
many attempts by
the federal government and state
government to try to ban things and in
particular ban the distillation of
alcohol and ban the creation of beer and
wine
and all of the problems that came up
when you try to make something illegal
um i i think that that we were right in
1933 to repeal that and change to
regulation
um i think that the technology 100 years
later certainly is there
i think it's
matured
for uh having these machines similar to
bread makers and microwaves
i have a bread maker in my home i have a
microwave in my home we have appliances
in our home that are thoroughly tested
and i would i would say that uh the
safety issues have already been been
well
solved but i i just feel like banning
something like home distillation as a
hobby i i feel like that's that's a
repeat of prohibition and they were they
were pretty clear in 1933 that
prohibition was uh was a complete
disaster
okay
i guess when you're talking about the
concert i was thinking about george
washington's first crisis was the
whiskey rebellion and the attempted
attack whiskey
okay that's a good point too okay your
hands up simply because it's still up
and have there is no more discussion on
the motion to retain the clerk will call
the role
oh representative okay sorry
is your hand up because you have you
want to say something chris are you just
taunting me with your hand
yes i uh
um if i get this correctly
the itl
uh if it goes to it
i mean uh
retain fails retain
if if it goes if it is retained
um uh
the changes that might be made in my
opinion could make this uh worthwhile so
uh for that reason i'm going to allow
i'm gonna
i'm gonna vote in in favor of retaining
the bill
fair enough
okay the clerk will call the role um on
retaining
representative patosik
yes
representative osborne yes
representative ammon yes representative
abramson i
representative ham
yes
representative de palma
representative greeson
yes
representative johnson
yes representative terry yes
representative bartlett
no
representative abel
representative herbert
yes
representative van haltman
no
representative fargo no
representative weston
no
representative bill you
representative burroughs
yes
representative
mclean
representative hunts
yes
okay that is 1226.
all right moving right along
uh
house bill
449 right to repair home appliances
representative abramson second by
representative patusik moves in
expedient to legislate representative
abramson is recognized to speak to his
motion
so
i moved itl
this again was another bill that i
really liked when i first saw it saw the
title and then we opened it up and
looked at it
what the build actually would do though
is require that manufacturers
sell parts to just absolutely anyone
that they wouldn't have any control over
their own logistics and their own
infrastructure the giveaway uh requiring
that they give away um
tech manuals and material that could
include some internal information
there were safety issues that were
brought up
from manufacturers and
i didn't see anything to counter that
but the bill also opens up
all sorts of issues on regulating
interstate commerce and constitutional
and federal issues and legal issues
that i i felt would be a little
too difficult to retain and i also felt
that the bill had
uh structural issues we can't solve
structural issues internally within the
committee so it would have to be sent
back for the the sponsors and the
stakeholders to work out something
different
and the final problem that i that i saw
with the bill
is
that it really hurt the new hampshire
advantage that manufacturers who want to
sell to new hampshire new hampshire
customers they don't have to sell the
product in new hampshire so you'd have a
manufacturer
of appliances or
i don't know electronics or something
that they wanted to sell to new
hampshire customers but instead of
selling them here their only options
would be to sell them in vermont maine
you know main outlet store and north
shore mass and some of the other
retailers and then we would lose all of
the jobs all of the public and private
revenue all of the local revenue and we
would lose any ability to control it
so certain manufacturers especially
foreign manufacturers would have a
difficult
time with this and
i was trying to you know figure out or
estimate what could be the potential
revenue loss from enacting this and i
it's kind of the rabbit hole once you
you know i like the idea but once you
actually try to use the state government
to implement it it just started creating
more and more problems that that
couldn't be solved by the committee so i
think that it's another one where you
have 20 states considering this
legislation this year and you have more
states considering it in the previous
session and none of them have passed it
because they've run into a lot of the
same problems
great representative abel
thank you
with all due respect for
to representative abramson
i think he is is reading things into
this bill that
in real practice will absolutely not
happen
we have to remember first of all that
new hampshire having no
sales tax
that many people who live near the
border and other states come into
our state to buy
uh buy appliances and so forth uh that's
not gonna that's not gonna change the
second thing about this bill
um
[Music]
is that this is really friendly
to small
businesses independent repair people
uh we are helping small businesses
by supporting this bill
and that's why
i want to support this bill thank you
bartlett
thank you mr chair i'm flabbergasted
that um some from the other side are
they want to protect big business
um not allow repairs this is just for
home appliances
this bill has been um scaled back
dramatically from what we've read what
we've seen in the past
um i think that the small business
owners that just want to repair
home appliances should be able to do it
and they need to be able to access the
information
that the big government is keeping them
from being able to access
so you're going to protect
the big manufacturers from the little
guys that just want to go out and
fix the washing machine or fix you know
we were talking last night about a
toaster oven well you're probably not
going to get fixed that fixed but some
of these washing machines and dryers are
putting a lot of money into
um and you want to be able to just have
a local guy repair it you don't have to
make an appointment from somebody in
manchester that's got to come out three
weeks from now in the meantime you
haven't been able to use your washing
machine
when many of those fixes are very simple
and the small repair shop ought to be
able to access it
so
i'm definitely opposed to the itl and i
will be supporting an otp
representative terry
yes uh thank you mr chairman in point of
fact
many of the manufacturers
do make
the plans and the parts available
for
small independent repairs and
do-it-yourselfers such as myself so i do
not see this as a widespread problem
whatsoever thank you
uh representative abramson
um just a quick um
response that you have an absolute legal
moral and constitutional right to
attempt to repair anything that you want
that you own that's your property or to
to go to any independent repair shop
but so
you have a right to repair as it is it's
not the title of the bill
that i'm objecting to it's what the bill
actually says and what the bill says is
if you sell appliances in new hampshire
you have this specialized
you know front loader
um that
it's very unusual
a lot of companies make their tech
support manuals and parts
in such a way
that
that they can have hands-on training or
a specialized training program in person
where they they instruct people on how
to replace certain parts
and if you then have to take all these
tech manuals
especially for a small manufacturer that
only produces a few specialized items it
would be really difficult or maybe even
impossible for them
to
rewrite all of their tech support
manuals and remanufacture all their
parts and include
additional inserts for all their parts
so that people could do it yourself in
your home or for people who have no
training or for independent repair shops
i have several independent repair shops
just in walking distance of me here in
seabrook and we're right on the border
so
one it's it's a takings and two it's a
it's a mandate and it's i hear members
from the other side saying oh big
manufacturers but usually when we're
talking about companies that make very
specialized parts
um they're
the more specialized they are um small
businesses tend to focus in
in in very small niche markets i know
that there are companies like apple and
samsung that make
specialized parts too they're
multi-billion dollar giants but
um if some new startup wants to come up
with a new type of small engine or a new
type of rotary engine or a new type of
battery or something like that that
doesn't have user serviceable parts
their only solution if they're if
they're trying to sell those products is
they couldn't sell them in new hampshire
and so i saw this as for those types of
companies the only recourse they would
have it would be to sell them in other
surrounding states
uh so next up is representative bartlett
thank you mr chair this bill is very
specific about what a home appliance is
it's not talking about specialized small
manufactured
types of products
i
would challenge you to find a small
manufacturer that this would apply to
these are large manufacturers home
appliances include
cleaning cooking or food preservation
air conditioners dishwashers clothes and
washers washers dryers freezers
refrigerators kitchen ovens these are
made by large manufacturers
and if they if a small repair shop
cannot get a handbook or cannot get a
password they will be restraining their
their trade from being able to
access it and again i'm very surprised
that the other side
is making it more difficult for
small businesses to be able to go out
there and repair and protecting
um these these large manufacturers
representative burroughs
yes thank you um just to the to the
argument that the manufacturers are
going to have to rewrite their manuals i
would venture to assert that um people
who are skilled in uh
the repair of these appliances
um are not going to find those manuals
to be rocket science and that they'll be
able to utilize these to fix the parts
and if they can't they can always tell
the consumer um this is beyond what we
can do right now but again my guess is
these people do this for a living
they're used to using these manuals and
and most of them should be able to do
just fine with the manuals as written
so
um uh obviously in past years uh the
legislation seen the people who came in
and testified and supported it was the
computers and phones and you know what i
would call the hype
you know type things but this bill
doesn't include any of that right this
bill simply goes uh to the more uh more
mundane appliance
than that but
at the end of the day my argument
against this bill is the exact same
argument against i had that bill and
that is does the right of the
manufacturer
choose who he wants or she wants to
service their equipment
that is it their right to decide that
they don't want some unauthorized
um somebody who you know with with a i
guess
an appliance shop
that's going to service these type of
equipment and um when it comes to
modern modern-day equipments they are
very sophisticated computers and
electronics
and that they have you know maybe they
have a very strict procedure about how
you take the thing apart and they don't
really want anybody who isn't an
authorized service tech mucking around
because if they mix up something else
they could make do more damage than they
were they could it would have done and
and you know the manufacturer might be
stuck having to replace parts that they
shouldn't have had to replace because it
was an unauthorized service tech who
took it apart so uh it's the same same
issue i've always had is that um i think
manufacturers have a right to decide who
they uh want to sell parts to who they
want to give manuals to and who they
want to be servicing their equipment and
i've never heard anybody you know worry
about
um you know they're saying oh boy i got
a zero refrigerator that cost me three
thousand dollars much like a computer
that i want to bring it to any joe
schmoe to have it fixed um i think you
you're more apt to call the authorized
service center anyway so so this i
really think this legislation is
unnecessary
uh who's up first
uh representative herbert
yes
okay um
i i understand your reasoning in terms
of being able to have to choose
who can buy their stuff
but i'm uh
i'm uh
i think that
it's difficult for me to imagine that
that's how the system works in any way
shape or form because once i buy it it's
mine exactly not
and so if i if i want to go and have
somebody make a repair and i'm confident
that they're good at that that's my
choice
uh so um
i'm in favor of the bill and and for
that reason uh
i mean if i buy a ford
and i know somebody's competent uh and i
take it to a garage
and i have a competent garage that i go
to and i've taken
and and never had a problem so
so uh so it's uh i think i think i i'm
in the favor of you know these people
are good at what they do they make a
living at it
uh control uh over the the product
and uh i i don't think that they have a
right to do that
so uh
that's it i'm you know i'm not gonna
that's my vote's gonna be in that regard
and and uh go ahead representative
abramson
so i should have mentioned this before i
i write embedded software
um i went to rensselaer to study
electrical engineering on how to build
and develop hardware like this
i had a housemate who worked in
appliances and he was really good at
repairing
you know basic mechanical things and he
could fix 90 percent of the problems
even in
something that's very specialized but
the just the clock the control unit in
in the gas oven
um
the the that that component may be made
by a small company that then sells the
ge or maytag or one of the big
manufacturers
the the cpu the microprocessors are
getting much more complicated they're
far more just the embedded processors
inside your smartphones
the 64-bit arm i was going to write a a
a tech book on that
and
the the complexity of the cmd extensions
the 64-bit uh memory mapping i mean i
couldn't even begin to explain
how to
i
you know update the uh the flash memory
um or do device driver updates for my
friend who does nothing but repairing
appliances my housemate who does nothing
but repairing appliances and and some of
these shops in seabrook are really good
but when they get into the really
complicated technical issues they're
smart enough to say
you know we're not going to get into
this you need you'd need a a an
electrical engineer with a four-year d
you know
with tools that we don't have in order
to to break down the electronics on this
and try and reprogram or update it or
calibrate the the sensors for for these
these appliances they're the independent
shops are smart enough to know not to
even attempt to do that and
for
you know for cars for the ecu units and
whatnot we wouldn't we wouldn't think of
having the abs system for a car
be reprogrammed by a regular local shop
they would send that to the dealership
the dealership has very very expensive
equipment that they use just for
reprogramming ecu's well a gas stove
has just as much uh potential for a
hazard for fire explosion if if the uh
the ecu if the
the microcontroller if the if the
computer unit for that
uh fails
um
you know there are real safety issues
and if
for some of these engineers making these
specialized control units um
for their own sensors for their own
devices for their own uh control servos
if you if you don't understand what
you're doing it does all the bill does
is it tells the company that they now
have to rewrite all their tech manuals
their videos and everything else for
people whom they haven't trained
um
i i i just i just can't see mandating
this i just see too many problems
legal problems and safety issues coming
up trying to mandate this a lot of
unintended consequences
all right i i think we
beat this horse dead
okay uh is the
question clear the motion is to in
expanding the legislating house bill
449. the clerk will call the roll
and before i do uh one little tip for
zoom if you hold down the space bar
uh while you're talking and let go it'll
it'll temporarily unmute you so
representative patusik
yes
representative osborne
yes but your trick doesn't work on my
device
representative ammon yes
representative abramson
aye and the space bar works for me
cool representative ham yes
representative de palma yes
representative greeson
representative johnson
yes
representative terry yes
representative bartlett no
representative abel
no
representative herbert
van halton
no
representative fargo no
representative weston
no
representative bill you
representative burroughs
no
representative mcaleer
representative hunts
yes
10 to 8.
i'll do the minority report on that one
okay
all right mr chairman
yes
i just want to let you know i have class
at 12. um i'm just gonna pull it up on
zoom so i'll be in two things at once so
if you see me talking to somebody it'll
just be
my other class so this won't be surgery
where you're trying to have a i said
that on tv
report the surgery
one on my phone and then just do one on
my computer so then i have both going
uh okay okay you're st you're at home
right you're you're not going to class
okay
um i i guess i guess we can we'll do
this i mean i um
we're doing pretty well here we got
two-thirds of it done you know so but i
guess if we'll keep going um
until people are had enough
okay
uh so next up is house bill 451
auto insurance limits uh representative
terry seconded by representative patusek
moves
in expedient to legislate and represent
terry is recognized to speak to his
motion
uh mr chairman is this bill amended i
see an amendment from
representative infantine what do we do
anything with that no because okay
my opinion is we're going to do
amendments we're going to delve into all
that we wouldn't want to do that
thank you then then i'm all set to go
mr chairman and honored colleagues
at first blush this bill appears to be
seeking a reasonable increase in minimum
motor vehicle insurance limits however
we heard compelling testimony that in
fact the likely effect of enacting this
bill would discourage drivers from
obtaining or keeping auto insurance
because the increased minimum coverages
would provoke higher premiums
at a time when scores of our state's
residents are struggling to find or
retain gainful employment
and gasoline prices are rising
dramatically this is not the time to
mandate an additional increase to the
cost of driving
and finally mr chairman i find it deeply
troubling that this bill's sole sponsor
is employed in the insurance industry
and potentially stands to gain
financially from the passage of this
bill i move itl
jesus okay
uh representative abramson has his hand
up
i just wanted to make the point that uh
if if we wanted to inflation adjust it
um that
um while i agree with the itl motion uh
the amendment would just change it from
25 50 25 to 30 60 30 so it would um i
didn't have a problem with the amended
version
but i i do have a problem that we're
trying to get people into insurance get
people into auto insurance who currently
don't have it
and i i've
felt that maybe we should even lower the
minimums
because we want uh auto insurance to be
as affordable as possible especially for
people who haven't had it in a while
and the sponsor wasn't real
um i didn't i didn't
uh i didn't think that there was a
conflict of interest
uh because uh they know that if they did
double the
the minimums that they would sell fewer
new insurance policies so he might
actually
um he wasn't enthusiastic about the bill
because he might actually lose some
sales for it
okay uh representative bartlett thank
you very much mr chair
okay well
this is one hit the wrong button it's
trying to lower my hand um
this is one that
with my background i have got to support
we're talking about at least 40 years
according to the insurance department
since these
minimums were raised now 40 years ago
a 2550
uh 25 policy
would have paid for a lot of claims
most claims are small
but
when these limits haven't gone up
and the and claims that do come in are
much higher than they were you'll end up
paying a total much more often so the
rates do go up that's the way rate
making works
um the examples that uh representative
infantine gave us who's the sponsor on
this showed that maybe a 17 year old's
paying four thousand dollars now he's
only gonna pay another three hundred
dollars well by the time he's paid four
thousand three hundred isn't a whole lot
and for the other people that are
wait i mean if you already got four
thousand dollars
that you're paying 300 is not a huge
increase on that
however
um
or you know people that are more average
drivers to increase
to a um
a little bit higher is is only about a
hundred dollars more
um i'm i am also the one who spoke on
the floor last year when well i guess it
was the year before now um
when we were talking about our new
hampshire being the only
state
that does not have mandatory auto
insurance
auto insurance really has become social
insurance much more like workers comp
um
because everybody drives
we have we've had in the past hours and
hours of testimony about
um what it's like to be hit by an
uninsured driver and our uninsured rates
have gone up dramatically over the last
decade because so many
people that are not insured
and are at fault in an accident your
policy lands up paying and the way that
you pay for that is all everybody that's
got an insurance policy
pays into that pool
um i you know i have a pretty good idea
i'm gonna lose on this one
but this is one of my principled stands
that's all
okay
representative abel
yes thank you um i want to say that our
illustrious my uh committee minority
leader uh ranking member excuse me
ranking member uh
said exactly what i was going to say um
and so i i certainly support her
position
that
keeping these uh minimums as low as they
are is just rate it's just keeping up
our uninsured and underinsured motorist
part of our of
our policies
higher than it ought to be so i i agree
with her and i i am against the itl
okay i kind of missed that one but
um i i would have to say i was surprised
to see how many states that actually
were
their minimums were even lower than ours
i was uh kind of awestruck that kind of
scary when you when you drive in those
other states and realize that oh great
we got they have mandatory auto
insurance but the limits were so low
that it doesn't seem like it really
matters but at the end of the day i
would hope that every
auto insurance salesman knows you need
to sell it up you need to move the
customer up need to get higher rates um
and for those of us who want to have an
umbrella
we're we're at the top anyway so it
doesn't affect us
and um i think that the fact that we
have a very well insured market we have
people who can make choices and decide
what are the right limits for themselves
and
and uh and i think that that
our auto insurance market is does not
need to be disrupted with changing this
and and we've already had a bad
experience once when many years ago when
we tried to change the
the med pay and and uh and i could i
can't tell you that that bill was
repealed faster than than campgrounds
so
when we tried the tax campaign so uh to
me changing these rates would it would
only be disruptive to the marketplace
okay any more discussion on the motion
see none the clerk will call the rule on
any speeding to legislate on 450.
okay representative patusik
yes
representative osborne
representative ammon yes representative
abramson
aye
representative ham yes
representative de palma
yes
representative greeson
representative johnson
yes representative terry
yes
representative bartlett
space bar
sorry
no
representative abel
representative herbert
no
representative van halton
yes
representative
fargo yes
representative weston
representative
sorry my phone is ringing um
oh
[Music]
representative burroughs
yes
representative mcleary
representative hunt
yes
vote is fourteen to four
okay
i will do the minority report
all right well that
keeps it on the
regular calendar
okay uh house bill 462
condolene
representative johnson seconded by
representative patusik moves in
expedient to legislate representative
johnson is recognized to speak to her
motion
good afternoon
um i think this bill needs way too much
work
and i think it would especially right
now would be more detrimental to our
citizens and to our banking industry and
everybody involved if we um
even tried to pass this so retaining it
needs too much work i i want to itl it
and let it
get some more work done
okay any other discussion on the motion
of uh in expanding to legislate on
62.
okay
all right clerk will call the roll
when he's ready
representative patosik yes
representative osborne yes
representative amman yes representative
abramson aye
representative ham
yes
representative de palma yes
representative greeson
yes
representative johnson
representative terry yes
representative bartlett yes
representative abel yes
representative herbert
yes
representative and hounton
representative fargo
representative fargo space bar
did she drop
yeah no yes yes yes
okay
representative wesson
yes
representative bill you
representative burroughs
yes
and representative mcelier
representative johnson up three hunt
that's your
okay
so 18-0
15-0
miracle
okay um
all those in favor of placing house bill
462 on the consent calendar please say
aye
all right
well i suppose
so moved in unanimously
okay
uh
house bill 466
uh condo pecuniary benefits
representative johnson second by
representative patouzik moves in
expedient to legislate representative
johnson is recognized to speak to her
motion
hi
thank you um this
um when a condo association it has known
that many association members has to do
maintenance and repairs on their own
associate association properties this
helps support local businesses and their
neighbors
this also helps lower the cost as the
condo members also
benefit and
helps them take pride in their own work
uh restricting
would harm the relationships between the
condo
and undergo undue government regulations
on private members and association
members
so i
support the itl
hey representative bartlett
thank you mr chair
it's really interesting um
what a difference a year makes this one
on the consent calendar last year was
unanimous vote out of our committee
yeah really i looked it up mr chair i
voted for it
you did
but
i will support the idea
okay representative fargo
um yeah i remember this really well too
i think this was brought to us by ellen
reid last term and we amended it to say
um
that just the person who would be
providing the service just has to recuse
himself from the boat doesn't mean that
he can't do the maintenance it doesn't
mean that
anything changes he just can't vote for
himself which which i still think is is
fair
um so i just i just wanted to raise that
point
all right any more discussion on the
motion have been expedient to legislate
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
representative patosik yes
representative osborne
yes
representative ammon yes representative
abramson
aye
representative ham yes
representative de palma
yes
representative greeson
representative johnson
representative terry yes
representative bartlett
yes
representative abel
now
representative herbert
yes
representative van haltman
representative fargo
yes
representative weston
representative bill you
yes
representative burroughs
representative mclear
representative hunts
yes
17 to one
okay
uh any problem with putting this on the
consent calendar representative
boy this is my big chance here i no i
it's fine go ahead
all those in favor placing the consent
calendar please say aye
aye
opposed so moved unanimously
okay um
house bill 477 internet outage
reimbursement representative terry
secretary representative
moves in expedient to legislate
representative terry is recognized to
speak to his motion
uh yes could you give me a moment uh mr
chairman i have to find
uh i have to find my right up here on
this bill
which one is it for
seventy seven four seven seven seven
internet outages
it's a good day for it
very appropriate
consumer protection guy came in and said
boy
well i don't have there's the
robocops yeah
the outreach one
is there a chance we might be able to
have a lunch break after this one
we're doing really well it looks like
we're going to get this done this
afternoon would people want to stay i
mean i guess uh joe how is that this
work for you what's your afternoon
schedule
um would it be when would be coming back
1 30
um
we could do that and maybe yes
because i have a class so i have this
class ends at 115 and then i have
another class at 2.
so
represent fargo
thank you mr chair i get my vaccine this
afternoon and have to leave by three so
if we take a lunch break can we keep it
a little bit shorter than we normally do
so that we can um finish so i can be
part of finishing today
right okay no we definitely want to do
that because we have the same problem
with chrissy tomorrow one hour
um
so
um so so joe what did you say your class
schedule didn't drop my mind i know i
must have it written down somewhere
was your
i'm sorry what was that what was your
class schedule again um for today so i
have this class ends at 1 15 and then i
have another class at 2 to 3 15.
okay
sure if you're ready to go on this bill
right now i'm ready but if you want to
hold it over that's fine
let's just do this one let's do this
make this through
okay
uh
thank you mr chair this bill should be
itl for two reasons
uh first it would address a problem
whose magnitude and frequency have not
been established as well as to presume
internet service providers egregious
failures to address service outages
inappropriately or not at all
second the bill requires that internet
service providers be responsible for
determining both who is responsible for
customers out of service statuses
and then precisely how long each
of the service time lasted out of
service time lasted
that can be attributed with certainty to
the service provider
then third and with respect to the
bill's provisions penalizing isps for
not meeting advertised speeds
it must be recognized that isps make
clear that there are variable factors
that affect each customer's upload and
download speeds
not the least of which are factors that
are not the responsibility of the of any
isp
such factors include the number and
types of customer devices utilizing
bandwidth at any given time
and the fact that internal wiring is
neither owned by nor the responsibility
of the isp
in summary this bill would introduce
onerous and unjustified government
regulation in a type of commerce
that while not as yet widely available
in modern high-speed modes as we would
like is nevertheless not guilty
of the offenses this bill wishes to
remedy by its draconian unjustified and
unworkable standards and requirements
thank you
okay representative abramson
um i agree with the itl motion
um i
so i disagree i certainly think that
this is a serious problem and it
certainly is in seabrook where i live
where we have uh internet outages um
quite frequently um even though we're
paying a top dollar for service but i
believe that the solution is to open up
internet service providers to
competition
um
that that would benefit consumers more
and it would benefit businesses more
especially those in tech support and
businesses that need
uh teleconferencing and telepresence and
other things things that require 100
uptime um
so
but trying to change this this bill as
structural problems trying to change
this bill into something completely
different um it might even end up going
in front of a different committee would
be uh
not something we can do internally we
have to send the issue back to the
sponsors and stakeholders for for change
on that magnitude
okay any more discussion on the motion
of any speeding to legislate seeing none
the clerk will call the role
representative batusik
yes
representative osborne
representative ammon yes representative
abramson
aye
representative hand
yes
representative de palma
representative greeson
yes
representative johnson
representative terry
yes
representative bartlett
representative abel yes
representative herbert
yes
representative van halton
representative fargo
yes
representative westender
representative bill you
yes
representative burroughs yes
representative mcelier
representative hunt
yes
18 to zero
okay 18 to zero okay uh all those in
favor of placing on the consent calendar
please say aye
that was opposed
so moved unanimously
uh
okay well why don't we
why don't we take a break now
and come back at uh
15.
okay
um just let everybody know i had an
amendment i just distributed to
everybody regarding the um
the restaurant delivery service it's
house bill 5
93. when i ordered it originally i had
the wrong number i put in 5.92 so i just
asked for a corrected
amendment
okay so hopefully we get it back and
i'll get it out to everybody
why don't you tell everybody what's in
the amendment
um the amendment is to
uh make it effective upon passage but
also to put a two-year sunset clause in
so that um we'll see you know we it
would hopefully help these small
restaurants right away but then you can
see and take a look at it afterwards to
see whether um it needs to continue
and uh and i agree with this concept
that's good
okay all right we'll see we'll see you
again
i have a three o'clock um this afternoon
we're going to be done before three okay
all right
have a good lunch
you're coming back
so we're gonna come back at 1 15.
and please
be timely so we can
miraculously get this all done before
three
okay
all right i see you're
putting it up there thank you pam
ah
there we go
well it's gone pretty smoothly i thought
yes
john in honor of this being an exec i
had a half and half for lunch today
what's a half and half
same thing we usually have over uh
across the street when we have exact a
half a sandwich and a half a cup of soup
wow okay
i had a salami sandwich
smells good yeah it is
i had stuff i had stuffed shells yum
that sounds good we had a we had a baked
ham the other day and i had a ham and
swiss
well my husband doesn't eat meat and um
and i can eat whatever i feel like
i went shopping and that's the end with
salami it just sounded so good oh yeah
um i mean i can live without meat but
and he's an easy man to live with
but occasionally i just have to have
some
yeah i didn't even have to make these
stuffed shells they came from my
restaurant so it was even better
and did everybody see the amendment i
sent out yes i got it printed and it's
in the it's in the bible
it must have been 10 o'clock last night
when i sent it out and i just picked the
wrong number
when i saw it i went oh rats
well we we know the intent
well i i apologize to courtney profusely
and she got it turned it right back
around so beautiful
just had to change the
house bill number and the amendment
number
but i really hope we can help these
small restaurants yeah
this is a big help
like i said i talked to some of the
local folks in derry and they're having
the same problem yeah
and you know these are these are my
neighbors these are my friends
but you know i
i wouldn't have had any idea we don't
use delivery from restaurants but um i
wouldn't have any idea that they didn't
have to have a contract
and the fact that they take the tips too
bothered me
yeah that that's
right there so the restaurant i work for
a couple nights a week we've had this
happen to us so i talked to the owner
you know and her thoughts and and
because we've had people call up and say
you know where's my order i'm like we we
don't know what you're talking about
and so you know this amendment and and
this bill is something that's definitely
needed because i didn't realize either
because you need and i didn't know
anything about it until you know we got
here so this is one that is definitely
needed
because you know it's just fun
could you send me a copy of that
amendment
of course i'm sorry pam
that's why we put a sunset date on it if
everyone agrees that it's like a
terrible thing why why why are we
putting a sunset on it
gives us another session
um well because
i don't i don't understand the full
consequence of this and frankly i really
do believe it's the response
responsibility on their own web page to
let people know
whether they have a contract or not
um
that
[Music]
i
agree with you on that but the problem
is there they're advertising them
and who's getting the
um mr chair
um
representative
email regarding this
okay are we still echoing um no no
um
representative abramson says that we
can't do a
um
the amendment that we we talked about
about 60 days it has to it can't be upon
passage it has to be a 60 day
because the new hampshire
the new hampshire supreme court and i
think it's state law it might even be
house rules also that you can't have a
new law take effect upon passage we have
an enrollment period for one and you
have
where you have laws that might conflict
with other laws
or bills that might conflict with other
bills
going through the house and senate
but i just
emailed legislative services and saw if
i could get a 60-day
you know delay for this takes effect
within 60 days of passage
so um i've covered this
issue before and um there is a actual
statute an rsa that says
the type of legislation
and what the effective dates are
supposed to be
and so that's when bills come out of
legislative services they're going to
have all those numbers on it but we're
the legislature so we can do whatever we
want
and we want to be effective upon passage
that's right
now
if there is somebody who says there's a
problem with it or something like that
they can take it up in the senate but i
i've been down this path before max and
i can assure you that if we want to say
upon passage we can say upon passage
and i think that that's
i think that that's bad practice on top
of that if it's a new penalty if it's a
repeal it's different but the new
hampshire supreme court has said if you
repeal something then the repeal takes
effect immediately or a reduction in
penalty takes effect immediately
but this is a new penalty this is a new
rule
max i do have an amendment in for 60
days by the way that was the original
amendment that
amendment up to but i don't know um
so pam i i hate to do this yesterday
research on did the supreme court really
order that we can't do that
it's um
well it's on criminal law so that was
the research i was doing
so it might be different because the
judiciary has to update all their forms
so they'd like to have things take
effect
january first of the next year to give
them enough time to change all their
forms but you're still going to have
state agencies that have to enforce this
no i think this is private right of
action
i need to pull the bill up but i don't
remember this being a criminal
but that would even if it's private
right of action it's still going through
civil war private right to
i understand that but
i will
see what i can find out so this was a
recent
new hampshire supreme court decision
representative abramson oh
that was uh before even the savings
clause this is um
i want to say 2001 that that's a
criminal case so they they may not it
may not apply here
tons it doesn't you're adding a new law
you're adding a new penalty
um we've usually allowed
just a certain amount of time to make
sure that you're i think i want to
require someone to do something that
they can't do okay i would say in
defense of this statute and and i'm not
a lawyer nor do i pretend to be one the
defense of the statute is what um these
doordash what they're doing is already
the court has already ruled in favor of
the restaurants
for just this issue
so
this is um this is president when i got
used to you you know last year
uh parliament williams would keep
telling me this is this is uh belts and
suspenders
because we're actually reinforcing a
case law that's already occurred
because this was the one that um the
owner of the t-bones um tom boucher
he had the wherewithal to be able to sue
and he won
but this but it was only for
his case
um and so that's why this was brought
forward and
it'll you know the we have the testimony
from the small restaurant owners that
are being affected too right
and there's
then
at any rate that's the reason why we're
sun setting so we could revisit it again
within two years to see whether
you know and to be fair i mean we we
discuss this and
we want to help the restaurants we want
this to go through
we probably should be talking about this
when we're
on the bill
that's true too part three of the bill
any food delivery platform that violates
this chapter shall be guilty of a
violation and find one hundred dollars
for each delivery made without the
agreement required in paragraph two
okay you're right so i i i
i'm not even sure if 60 days
somebody might uh
change it again in the senate they might
say jen you go back to the original
january 1st
if it makes you happy
you can certainly then take up
connie's amendment after we passed that
amendment which then would take it back
to 60 days
nothing makes me happy my m3 is not
running
just saying
i always thought the legislature can can
and
repeal its own law you know you know no
legislature can uh
uh
supersede a future legislature so i
always
change our
own rules but well i mean yeah
let's get going
all right uh
so where are we at we're at 48 48 488
okay
representative greeson second by
representative patouzik moves to retain
house bill 488
and representative uh
griezmann is going to speak to his
motion
okay yeah sorry about that i i got uh
booted out of the uh the session there
unfortunately i was able to get back in
time here uh so uh house bill 488 the
original uh bill was to establish a
committee to study the benefits of
allowing new hampshire citizens to
purchase health insurance from
out-of-state companies and in uh
discussing the bill it was determined
that the
uh the direction that this committee
would be going in may not be
um
may not be the right direction or or we
need more guidance and so
uh i'm moving to retain it so that we
can give it some more guidance we can
make sure we have the proper membership
on the committee give them a little bit
more specific uh for example it was
brought up making sure that they uh look
into single-payer uh the feasibility of
implementing free market driven health
care plans etc like a la carte plans
basically giving them more specific
directions to be able to come back and
give
better uh answers to uh to what we're
looking for because we're all we're all
aiming for the same thing we want to
bring people's out of pocket uh
healthcare expenses medical expenses
down and so how do we best go about
doing that and so if we retain it i
think we can we can give this committee
uh
uh a better direction
so by understanding the correct thing
you're it's not that you want to focus
on the outer buying health insurance
across state lines is that you would
like to have
work do some work and figure out how we
can make health insurance premiums lower
correct yes and if we give it more
direction then
specifying a little bit better a
course of action as opposed to the broad
statement uh that was initially
introduced then then we can make better
use of the committee
okay great representative bartlett
um i'll let somebody else on my side um
speak first i'll i'll um
speak afterwards
representative van houghton
uh thank you um this is a committee this
is only to set up a committee i i agree
with the scope of the committee that
that the charge of the committee would
be very very broad but to set up a
committee i think is is
just to go
into the deep end without a paddle um i
do think this is probably worthy of an
ito it might have some validity but i
think it needs to be totally reworked
and i think that's more than we can
handle we we as a legislature are taking
on many many bills valid bills that need
to be spruced up and spiffed up and put
back out but if we keep taking on on
very difficult tasks tests that are
unlikely to be
met i think that we are going to be in
difficulty and again we're talking about
a committee here which deals with
legislators rather than getting into the
experts from the legislature who i think
should probably be brought in
i just think it's too much i think uh
itl is the only the only direction that
i can see is as as workable despite the
intent of those people who brought it
forward thank you
okay uh representing uh fargo
[Music]
sorry i left it off but i i with the
echoing i turned a bit so
jeff i absolutely commend where you're
going with this and i'm glad to hear
that you're saying that you want to
expand it to look at more than out of
state but we've had so many i don't know
if you've looked into
um the committees and commissions that
have already been established that are
working on this now um i know jerry
kanark and and a team of people that he
was working with last term um
was really involved in this already and
i i'd wondered had you had an
opportunity to speak to anybody maybe
pam has information about this but i
think this is already being done um and
so for that reason i i think i would itl
this and i would
um maybe get involved or or look into
the commissions and committees that are
already looking at this very subject
already
i was not aware thank you for the for
the question i i i was not aware of
anything that was presently underway uh
it would certainly be we don't want to
duplicate efforts that just becomes a
waste of time
um but if we
uh
you know
i guess what it would come down to is
who's doing what
where are they in what they're doing and
when are they going to have something
finished that we can talk about
and so um if we
can come up with something that says
here's a fixed amount of time
explore the this direction come back
with your findings by
and
uh and then maybe maybe something
actually gets done about it because we
could send this thing off into the abyss
and nothing ever gets done about it we
sure felt good about looking into it and
so uh i i i think that if we
point it in the right direction and give
it a deadline maybe we'll come up with
something
okay representative abramson
um actually this is a question for the
chair on a retain motion
um if we do choose to to retain this can
the retainment itself be kind of done as
as like an ad hoc
subcommittee with the
not subcommittee but an ad hoc committee
of just volunteers who get together
discuss it maybe won't need a
subcommittee at all or a commission at
all
um well again
by retaining it we will will be able to
work on it in the in the fall
and in terms of anybody ad hoc wants to
work on it they can certainly do that um
at the end of the day the bill you know
either gets amended or gets killed or
gets re-referred for interim study can
have three different motions come come
next october november
okay and now you're ready representative
yes i am
thanks um i i appreciate everybody's
input on this one there's a
deadline on this committee that
commission
of november 1st of this year
two and so if we don't even look at it
until september or october
there's no time at all two
um it's a committee not a commission so
it's only members of the legislature who
are already going to be out straight in
september and october
three
it's so broad
that
three people four people can't do it
um and and
representative fargo's right we've we've
already got a commission working on this
um tyler brennan also came to us and we
do pay attention to what tyler says um
he says there's many providers many of
them are not licensed
um we need a local president and the out
of state carriers are going to have a
really tough time
being able to negotiate insurance
benefits
in state um so for all of those reasons
i
really don't think this is something
that a committee can look at by november
1st
um and i'm going to vote to itl i'm
sorry i
agree with the intent but
it it's
um
we're not going to be able to do what
the goal of the of the bill is
okay so the pending motion is to retain
representative johnson
so my question is if we retain it and we
find out that there is
other bills
out there that are similar
wouldn't that then you know by at least
us retaining making sure that the other
bills are out
there and then we don't have to worry
about it
but at least it gives us the opportunity
if we have to fix it to fix it later
we can certainly decide come this fall
whether this bill is necessary or not
okay is the motion clear to retain
clerk will call the role
batusik
yes
representative osborne yes
representative ammon yes representative
abramson
aye
representative ham
yes
representative de palma
representative greeson
yes
representative johnson
representative terry yes
representative bartlett no
representative
abel
no
representative herbert
representative van houghton
no
representative fargo
representative weston
no
representative value
representative burroughs
no
representative mcaleer
representative hunts
yes
the vote is ten to eight
okay
all right
moving right along house bill 510
robocalls
representative greeson second by
representative patusek moves in
expedient to legislate
is there really any need for discussion
on this bill
seeing none
the current all the role
i just need a minute to catch up sorry
okay
we're on house bill 510
it sounds like you have one of those old
ibm's electric type keyboards for your
computer
that wasn't me i don't know who that was
sounded pretty funny though
your memory goes back that far i can
barely remember those keyboards we had
one when i was a kid
i sold a lot of those ibm pcs and xt's
and ats that keyboard
we still have one in our house upstairs
commodore 64.
that goes way back that's the original
trash 80
that was the only uh commodore 64 was
the only computer that ever outsold the
ibm pc and i guess it did so for what
three or four years
it it was it lasted a while the cassette
tape being the beta backup was
not did not lend itself to stick around
for very long
but
okay we ready i'm ready and this is the
greason and seconded by patusik yes itl
510.
all right calling the role
representative patusik
yes
representative osborne yes
representative ammon yes representative
abramson
aye
representative ham
yes
representative de palma
representative greeson
yes
representative johnson yes
representative terry yes
representative bartlett yes
representative abel yes
representative herbert
he's he's there
hold down the spacebar took off his head
bar had headphones
headphones
you're up chris use your space bar
itl
yes yes
yes
perfect
representative van houghton
yes
representative fargo yes
representative weston
yes
representative bill you
representative burroughs
yes
representative mclear
representative hunt yes
eighteen to zero
okay all those in favor of placing ellis
bill 510 on the consent calendar please
say aye
aye
those opposed
some captioning not
[Music]
uh to available
and seconded by representative patusek
and this is a bill that got cut up in
the coven
shuffle and uh we would like to make
sure
so o2p
i'm okay in 2020
any discussion on the motion about to
pass
see no
clerk we'll call the rule when he's
ready
just need a second
uh what bill are we on right now
we're on 5 10.
i know 5 18.
5 18 right 18.
so greece uh representative hunt moves
on to pass all right
representative patusik
yes
representative osborne yes
representative ammon yes representative
abramson
aye
representative ham yes
representative de palma yes
representative greeson
yes
representative johnson
representative terry yes
representative bartlett yes
representative abel
yes
representative herbert
representative van halton
yes
representative fargo yes
representative weston
yes
representative bill you
representative burroughs
yes
representative mclear representative
hunt
yes
18 to 0.
placing on the consent calendar please
say aye
[Music]
those aye
so moved unanimously
all right moving along house bill 520 uh
this is the insurance department's bill
representative bartlett seconded by
representative hunt moves uh to pass is
there any need for a discussion on this
bill
no these were
just technical changes
requested by the insurance department
attorney silverstein
explained all the
ins and outs
and um i we're fine with it
everybody's good good
all right
uh the clerk will call the roll
on 5
20.
i just need one minute again here
so i was filling in
well actually i mixed it up with 519 and
520 this is the one that um
delivers the um insurance documents
electronically which is what's been
going on anyway
right um
and this is just putting it into statute
that the insurance companies can do that
all the most results pass by
bartlett
seconded by
seconded by home
all right
ah
representative michael is here
there you go
welcome back got his winter jacket on is
it cold or is it
did you have to go hike to find the
internet
i'm i'm i'm not at the house i'm uh
down in glen
restaurant so i have to be quiet
okay
probably once
wi-fi so i don't know whether that's
kosher
is that all right
well that's fine but yeah just say that
you're not alone
no i'm not alone
okay
we ready for a roll call
are you ready ready yep
all right
the motion is and i will rule that uh
mcleader is here for the motion uh as
ought to pass
representative patusik
definitely yes
representative osborne
yes
representative amman yes representative
abramson aye
representative ham
yes
representative de palma yes
representative greeson
yes
representative johnson
representative terry
yes
representative bartlett
i'm sorry could you put yourself on mute
yes
representative abel yes
representative herbert
yes
representative van houghton
representative fargo yes
representative weston
yes
representative bell you
representative burroughs
yes
and representative mcmichael are you
pass
you can't pass
um
representative mcaleer this is um
house bill 520
and it's regarding insurance companies
um
delivering
documents electronically
yes there you go
yes
okay 19 to zero
520 on the consent calendar please say
aye
will move unanimously
okay
oh some representative mcclaire get in
here for 5 27.
okay uh here we go um house bill 527
um representing
uh seconded by representative osborne
moves to retain
and representative patusek is recognized
to speak to his motion
thank you mr chairman
uh this bill has to do
adding additional definition for
qualified charitable gift annuity issued
by a charitable organization
i don't know about you but there's so
many tlas in here i was confused
uh
there's got to be clarification i my
notes
i've
looked at them and they still don't make
a lot of sense
um
an annuity is an insurance product
and it just
is confusing and i move
to retain it so i can get some more
knowledge and understanding of what this
is about
yeah i'll tell you the reason why i want
to retain this bill
is as you might remember it had uh two
limitations how long the charitable
entity existed the organization existed
and what its
net worth was
and um
and the uh the sponsor did send out an
amendment uh to try to just move those
numbers around
but um i actually again here i guess is
my old dog um we actually deal deal this
subject material gift annuities many
many years ago
when it came to um
nursing homes and
the other
and the issue was that people were
setting up terrible annuities and in
that we made a requirement that the the
non-profit had to have a million dollar
asset
and because the assumption was that with
a million dollar asset that they would
have the
somebody who's working who works there
who has the the horsepower to understand
what how this annuity works how to make
the investments and do the proper work
to ensure that the immunity the you know
the investments
were preserved so in that sense i want
to retain it and since it's really very
similar to what we dealt with already
i think that we can fix this correctly
but we could not do it now
so
first up is representative bartlett
i'm going to defer to representative
fargo or abolio and i will speak last
okay
i'll do that from now on
so next up is representative fargo
uh yes thank you mr chair i have a few
concerns about this that i would prefer
just to ideal this um tom donovan from
the um trust department has concerns
these um charitable annuities are not
regulated i think from a consumer
protection perspective
this could be dangerous again
similar to representative terry i think
this is a person who may be using
legislation to further his business and
i just not comfortable with this so um
i'm i
i'm going to vote against the retainer
and i would prefer to itles
right i understand that i did talk to
tom donovan and he his issue the
amendment that he that was sent out did
address his problem so in that sense he
was all set but i have to admit i was
not all set because i just don't think
um
you know the the the limits 25 or i
think he raised it to 50 or something
the limit
it's just too small and you're
the net asset of the charitable trust
and and i think we want to make sure
that when we pass this we um we are
doing proper consumer protection
i hope to do that through by retaining
it
representative
took her put her hand down so now you're
up bartlett
okay
um
i have some
concerns about this bill
um we've already identified what some of
them are i am willing to look at the
amendments
um and try to get a clearer picture of
i i think i understand what the goals
are but i don't understand the
mechanisms so i'm willing to go along
with the retention though it's going to
take an awful lot to persuade me
that
this is a good bill
fair enough
any other discussion on the motion to
retain
none
representative
yes
representative osborne
yes representative ammon yes
representative abramson aye
representative ham
yes
representative de palma yes
representative greeson
yes
representative johnson yes
representative terry yes representative
bartlett
yes
representative
abel
yes
representative herbert
representative van houghton
yes representative
fargo
no
representative
weston
no
representative bellew
representative burroughs yes
representative
mclear
yes
and representative hunt
16 to 3.
[Music]
uh
to consent or do you guys want on the
regular account
this was to retain sir oh that's right
we don't have to worry about it
okay
uh house bill 553 banning automatic
contract renewals representative palma
seconded by representative patusik moves
uh inexpedient to legislate
and representative would you like to
speak about it or i think we're all
pretty much ready to vote yeah if you
guys are ready to vote
okay uh well representative abramson has
a
something to say yes
actually this is another one of those
bills where i agreed with what they were
trying to do but when we opened up the
bill i saw
at least three different problems with a
bill and
in my case i would ask the sponsors to
come back next session with with
something else working with the
stakeholders but uh
i didn't think that the committee could
it's only two sentence bill and three
problems and
two sentence bills probably one too many
right
and hopefully next time he'll show up to
the hearing
okay
all right the motion is uh inexpensive
to legislate is the question oh
representative fargo
yes thank you mr chair um i guess i'm
gonna buck everybody again and say i i
don't see the three problems in the
three you know a little bit of a bill i
think it's a good consumer protection
bill and i i don't see any reason to
ideal it but
just
thanks
so do you have cable tv
you know you have do you have some
things you pay by credit card
and they automatically renew it every
year or so yeah but i don't see why an
email just uh
let you know that your renewals coming
up is a problem
okay
uh the motion is need to legislate
representative
you have
no okay
all right
is the clerk ready ready
okay
any speed to legislate
representative patusik
uh yes
representative osborne yes
representative amman yes representative
abramson aye
representative ham yes
representative de palma yes
representative greeson
yes
representative johnson
yes representative terry yes
representative bartlett no
representative abel
no
representative herbert
representative van houghton
i heard no is that regret that's correct
yes no is my answer
thank you representative fargo
representative
no
you're unmuted now and you muted it when
you gave your answer well no i'm sorry
representative hunt
yes
okay ten to nine
okay
on the calendar is there going to be a
minority report
there will be a minority report
okay
i want to do it i'm the only one having
a problem with this mute thing
who wants to do okay um representative
weston will do the minority report
okay
[Music]
and it also passes the motion
that's correct
thank you
okay
uh house bill 592
um
vaccine bond
representative greeson moves second by
representative patusek to retain
and representative greeson is recognized
to speak to his motion
uh thank you mr chairman uh so this uh
this bill uh proposes to establish a
means for those who've been injured by
vaccines to receive compensation and in
the uh in the hearings the number one
concern was will we buck up against the
federal program and otherwise there
didn't seem to be any objections to
doing something just making sure that
this would not be subsequently uh found
uh if in a legal challenge to to be
overridden by any federal program so i
uh i received uh and actually it was
unsolicited as somebody who was watching
the the hearings actually uh uh
it was an attorney and uh sent her
opinion that there should be no problem
with with going forward with this
legislation and so
obviously one is is one opinion and so i
am now actively seeking additional legal
opinions just to make sure uh but if
we're given a little bit more time i
think we can make this we can address
that issue uh then of course the uh
the department of health and human
services
whether or not they're the the
appropriate
uh uh agency to for controlling uh for
handling this so it just there's uh it
seemed to me that there wasn't any
opposition to doing something it was
just making sure that what we're trying
to do can be done and so give it a
little bit more time i'm actually able
to uh i'm reworking already i've been in
the process of doing that and so uh the
biggest hurdle being the preemption of
the federal program i think we've been
able to leap that so give it a little
bit more time we can plug the holes and
move forward with something good
okay
uh representative abramson had his hand
up first um i did receive a lot of
emails in support of this bill and
asking that something be done including
from constituents in my district so i'll
be supporting the retain and uh but it
does apparently require uh quite a bit
of legal research to get something done
on this
representative bartlett oh do you want
me to be last or you want to do that let
me be asked
okay uh representative abel
uh i i see the problem
uh with this bill being
that no
pharmaceutical company will post a bond
and so the only thing that can possibly
happen is
vaccines won't be available in the state
of new hampshire so i'm opposed to this
and uh would have a different motion
okay uh representative
thank you mr chair i totally agree with
what representative abel has said um it
just appears to be very quick a
knee-jerk reaction to a pandemic uh and
and
therefore the holes that were mentioned
by the sponsor perhaps are much too
large at this stage of the game to even
go to retention again i've said it
before and i'll say it again to retain
so many bills and to expect that in a
short time in september or october we
can bring them all to to do justice
especially those with as many holes as i
see in this one is is folly right now i
think we need to attend to those that
are fixable that that can be um
uh patched up and and brought to bear
for for our constituents and leave those
that are much larger to be repaired and
brought back in the next session thank
you
okay uh representative
thank you mr chair uh i too i'm going to
uh
i'd like to itl this bill
uh there are way too many problems and
uh i do believe that um if this bill
passes there um will be some issues with
um vaccination um that definitely needs
to happen thank you
okay representative greeson
i just wanted to address the uh
the idea that this is a knee-jerk
reaction to a pandemic uh actually this
bill does not focus on anything
covid related whatsoever this is all
vaccines uh regardless of the nature of
it uh so it is not a knee-jerk reaction
uh people have been having
uh issues with with vaccine injuries for
for many many years uh long before the
the uh the
timing of it sure uh we could be able to
take advantage of of anything i know of
nine deaths reported in the state of new
hampshire due to the covid vaccine uh
but uh as far as this the being the
impetus for this bill
none whatsoever
okay uh
i assume the uh uh
some of the hands are still up or just
to make sure i get the right people who
want to speak
uh representative bartlett
thank you mr chair
um
i i really believe that this is a way of
depressing
taking vaccines
by those that are opposed to vaccines in
general
i
don't think it's a
solution
to the problem this person um or this
this group seems to have and i will be
voting to itl this
okay uh all right so
uh representative fargo have did you
yes thank you mr chair
um i think this is a wrong message for
this time i think that people make a
choice whether or not they're going to
have a vaccine and they assume the risk
when they choose to be vaccinated
and um
i i agree with rich on this one i i
i think that if we did something like
this the pharmacy
may
decide that they don't want to offer
certain vaccines in new hampshire i
think this is a dangerous bill right now
and i think it should be itl
okay so so rich and connie did you guys
want to speak again or
uh okay representative van gaal
yes um i would just like to respond to
the idea that this is not a knee-jerk
reaction to the covet pandemic and it
may not be and i do respect the sponsor
and and his comments there um but i'm
wondering now if the intent of this bill
is to go back to all vaccine
providers for instance all those that
provide um
infant vaccine vaccinations vaccinations
that are required for school
administration i think we're opening up
if that's the case we're opening up a
very large ball of wax it'll be very
difficult to unravel and i'm even more
convinced than ever that itl is the only
direction to go here on that basis
okay
all right so uh
uh representative burroughs have you
spoken yet
thank you i just want to say i did a
quick fact check and there's been no
um on from a number of sources not just
one and there's been no proven links
between the vaccinations and deaths
there i i think there was a reference to
nine deaths um those were reported to
have been attributed to complications
from covet 19. cdc veers program
the cdc veers
that's exactly what they report or the
deaths due to uh due to vaccines and
they're reporting nine um
so what what
that's not just new hampshire you're
talking about the entire country there's
only been no that's the state state of
new hampshire
okay that's the federal the felony
program
from from where that's right that's
where i got the data there was a website
i'll have to take responsibility i i led
representative greeson to the federal
compensation which there is a federal
compensation plan already and
in fact and they're the ones who are
tracking this and so
he is he has found that piece of
information so uh i have no reason it's
not my numbers it's the cdc but give us
a website that we could look at look it
up
yeah no problem uh
it's it's through the cdc
and you just if you go to the cdc and
look up vaccine um but he's talking
about something specific i would like
him to give us the website
okay well all right
is that going to really change your mind
that if you found out that it wasn't
chairman do we have to do this
we're not going to do this right now
okay he will get that if if you're not
if you're not open to have your mind
changed i won't waste my time sending
you the link but it is the uh
centers for disease control they have
they call the va ers
uh and so you can look it up on your own
you can do a search for based on
symptoms and vaccine type and your state
you can do the search criteria and you
will come up with the number nine
okay
so uh representative abramson you still
have your hand up yeah it's a point of
order uh members we're not to uh cast
aspersions or or challenge the motives
of other members i heard that a couple
of different comments um i did have one
comment um that there is a vaccine
injury fund that's paid out i think it's
something over 4 billion dollars
but in the last 10 years very very few
people have even bothered
to
hire an attorney it's very difficult to
hire an attorney
and go after compensation which is
limited to two hundred fifty thousand
dollars and only six percent of people
have prevailed
uh so there are many many many times
more people who suffered injury death
disability autism or other types of
vaccine injury where
um they have have not even pursued it as
a legal issue because they know that
they have very little chance of
succeeding in court
okay
uh
is to retain
the clerk will call the roll
representative batusik
yes
representative osborne
yes representative ammon yes
representative eberson aye
representative han
yes
representative de palma
representative greeson
yes representative johnson
yes
representative terry yes
representative bartlett no
representative abel
sorry no
representative herbert
yeah
representative van houten
you muted
representative van halton
yeah the spacebar trick does not always
work i apologize my response is no thank
you
you have to have the zoom window as your
focused window for that to work so
thank you representative fargo no
representative weston
no
representative bellew no
representative
no
representative hunts
yes
that is 10 to 9.
okay
the dumps would be itl and there will be
a monarch minority report there's just
someone who wants to do it it's retained
oh you're right i'm sorry
okay uh so pam are you there
i am i have not
yeah i don't have enough information to
to research the case while you're
meeting
okay that's fine
um
i'd be happy to do it but
with the computer being used for the
zoom meeting i didn't have access to
that i'm just surprised that legislative
services would send us an amendment if
they knew that
that there was a problem with the
amendment they would have told us about
it i would think
i would have thought the same thing
so
so representative abramson are you is do
you really want to fall on your sword on
this one or can can we go with uh
uh upon passage because i i i feel like
i passed upon passage all the time i
feel like do it
at least session i feel like i passed
one or two bills that's upon passage
so i i i'm willing to go with this uh
representative abramson if you're
i mean if you want to vote no that's
fine but
um
how do you feel
you're muted
uh you're still muted not on muting oh
nope you unmuted and then you muted
yourself
oh there's another button for unmuting
i'm sorry did we move i'm sorry what was
the vote on uh
retained ten to nine
yeah oh
okay yeah we retained 592.
and we're at 5.93
now on 593. oh you're talking about the
amendment um wasn't it uh
representative van houden didn't uh you
have the one that takes effect in 60
days
yes
so shouldn't we just move forward on uh
her amendment well i like the sunset so
i would take the first amendment first
and then we can take up the second
amendment second which would then
replace the first amendment with that
length with the changing of the
uh
effective date
so would we need to move the
first we want to first move uh
representative bartlett's amendment that
was sent out
is that the that's the uh amendment
number 582
yeah
okay so representative uh bart second by
representative hunt uh moves out to pass
on the amendment 582 and representative
bartlett you're recognized to speak to
your motion thank you
i'm
trying to do this on the phone and on
here at the same time um
okay so
we all i think we all agree that um
we've got a problem with the delivery
services um and the small
restaurants are particularly being
affected whether they have
a website that can be updated regularly
whether these delivery services are just
automatically
putting it on their their website and
offering these restaurants as a possible
delivery
or whether they tell them or not
um
it bothered me a lot that they collected
the tips it bothered me a lot that if
there's a refund to be made by the
restaurant
the delivery service does not
do the refund it would have to come from
the restaurant and there's no
reimbursement from the delivery service
to the restaurant
um it bothered me that there was no
contract involved
in in these delivery services doing this
automatically for a hefty surcharge um
the example we had from mr boucher
the owner of t-bones in um copper door
and um cactus jacks
was that a 14 burger would end up
costing 29 when it was delivered
um and
and and quality couldn't be
guaranteed either because you know how
long it'll take for these delivery
services to actually deliver the meals
so
um
and that they have not that that unless
a small business is willing to
sue the delivery service they really
don't have much of a recourse
so my feeling is that this amendment um
changes the original bill from being
affected january 1st of 2022 which is
really too long to wait these these
restaurants need relief now
and during the pandemic there are people
that are
willing to pay
um the delivery service services um now
to be able to have a
a take-out meal
so one part of it was that when i spoke
with
the chair
we did discuss the bill um we did feel
that there was um need for relief right
now and in the spirit of negotiating an
acceptable
amendment that both sides could live
with i am willing to go along with a
two-year sunset clause
now that's my my personal feeling that
does not
uh commit
anybody else from from um
that discussion i just thought it was so
important that we get
this bill passed and over to the senate
as soon as possible
if the bill if the law needs to be
changed and um
delivery services go away or they change
their practices that would give two
years to be able to change it
and um i think that all of us are
motivated to
look into the situation and to come back
with changes if necessary before
december
of 2023
so that's the reason i um
was willing to bring the amendment forth
and um i hope that you can support it
okay uh representing van halen
thank you mr chair i'm in total
agreement that the relief needs to be as
soon as possible for these restaurants
and and uh small cafes and other food
purveyors i absolutely agree with that
and actually when i put the 60-day
amendment in i kind of thought it had to
be 60 days
i had that in the back of my mind and i
don't know if that relates to what
representative abramson has been saying
or not
however i do have a problem with the
sunset clause i don't think these issues
are going to go away just because the
pandemic may or may not go away in two
years we don't know what the
circumstances will be in a few years
future legislative legislations can make
that that
determination uh we also know that and i
i get the sense and i could be wrong
that most of us agree with the spirit of
this that we want to give some relief
and some support to these small
restrooms and businesses that are being
taken advantage of uh and so with that
in mind um
if we pass the 60 days and it's not just
because it's my my idea i'm very willing
to to go with a better idea at any time
if we pass the 60 days
and find that we can make it better in
the senate we can go there and lobby and
talk to our senators and get them to to
adjust things but at least we won't be
endorsing the sunset by by voting for
the the amendment with the sunset clause
in it we are endorsing the sunset
whereas i don't believe we should i
think we should leave it open-ended so
that we can support our restrooms into
the future if we find that it's wrong
future legislations can legislators can
make that adjustment and so i
i would prefer that we do not have a
sunset clause on this
and um
the people that i've spoken to the
constituents that are down here on our
main street which we call elm street are
hurting because of this their
reputations are hurting i simply don't
want that to continue i want that to
happen as in as timely a fashion as i
can but not in a way that will stop them
from having better business in the
future thank you
okay uh representative abramson
this was just a question of uh
representative bartlett um was it your
tent with this sunset that we come back
and revisit it or that you just wanted
it to be in effect for two years or you
wanted to see
what effect this has maybe in the courts
or in the marketplace before we come
back and and
and
reintroduce this as maybe a permanent
law
i can't tell you that
i was excited about putting it in but in
the spirit of
compromise and being able to move this
forward quickly i'm willing to go along
with it
representative abel
it took me a moment and i should have
done the space bar
i support uh having the sunset
or the reason that
i think it will make this bill uh more
likely to pass
um and
and so therefore i'm gonna vote for this
amendment but i'm not gonna vote for the
second amendment which would take take
this out i think this is an important
thing uh to have a two-year look back so
thank you
okay uh next up is
representative
suzek
um thank you mr chairman
uh i
as i stated before i physically went out
and talked to about a half a dozen of
our local small
restaurants
and i and they told me for a fact that
four of them have been
victims of the doordash
and i agree with representative bartlett
that it's it's a needed to be done now
asap
and the two-year look back i agree with
representative abel
that this basically mandates us in two
years to go back and look at it and
maybe
just reauthorize it or
make it even better
so thank you mr chair
okay pam now has something for us
i i just was looking at the rsa 14
colon 9a which is the law about
effective dates and it outlines
what effective dates the
office of legislative services must
include in the first draft of a bill and
the bill is introduced and it does say
that each law affecting judicial
practice and procedure or establishing
or eliminating criminal prohibitions
civil causes of action or remedies or
limitations of actions shall take effect
on january 1st following passage
however later in the same
law
when it talks about
amendments and it says the office of
legislative services shall at the
request of the sponsor of an amendment
include in the amendment the effective
date requested by the sponsor so
there's the list of effective dates that
are required to be in that
you know introduced bill and then
this does not answer the supreme court
decision that representative abramson is
is referring to it merely is what the
state law on effective dates is right so
that that's what the way i remembered it
which was the statute exists that was a
requirement on legislative services but
there's nothing encumbering the
legislature to put in whatever
effectiveness wants for instance i
remember when we did the
same day registration and we actually
made it effective uh three months before
we actually voted on it
so that can the legislature can decide
whatever effective data it wants
uh representative fargo's next
yes thank you mr chairman um
you know i think this problem existed
before the pandemic i think it's been
exacerbated because we do so much
takeout now i don't think it's going
away i think it should be passed
immediately but i i don't see having a
sunset clause because we don't even know
if we're all going to be here in two
years to go back and look at this and i
would
i would think it would be a disservice
to all the small restaurants who are
suffering under this to have two years
pass and nobody reopen this and look at
it i just i'm i'm totally i'm bored with
passing it immediately but i can't
support the sunset claws yeah the the
purpose of the sunset class is believe
you me if they want it in other words if
they get you know go through two years
and they're saying is this really did
turn out to be very important you know
legislation and we really do need it to
continue believe you me the restaurant
hospitality says you will not have
trouble finding a representative to put
in the bill to
to repeal sunset
the reason i think it's a good idea is
that
this is a pretty dramatic policy and i
think that we really want to make sure
we think about it normally this would
have been a bill i would have retained
or you know in an interim study to work
on it done done it right through
subcommittee but we didn't have time and
this is a where we all feel that this is
something we want to do now to help this
industry out right now and that's why i
think this is this
doing it this way makes a lot of sense
representative who's next representative
thank you mr chair um
the the underlying bill
i know we're talking about the amendment
uh
i'm just not gonna
right now
right now we're supposed to be talking
about the amendment right okay so i
think the two-year
sunset clause makes a bad bill slightly
better
um
and had i had i not thought we were
gonna
not retain this bill i might have put my
own amendment in
um
i'll be voting for the amendment but
against the underlying bill that's my
position
okay
and i'll speak to that when the bill
when we're talking about the bill fair
enough
uh so representative abel did you want
to speak again
nope okay and representative van
houghton
thank you
um
first of all just a quick point of order
i'm always confused as to how things go
when we have two or more amendments
um could you re repeat that process for
me please okay so we have this first
amendment that we we're going to take up
um if it were to pass
we still can take up you know we still
can have someone then bring in the
second amendment
and at that point time it would replace
that portion of the first amendment
which was the
um the the effective date
normal conditions we would have a third
amendment
you know drawn up to reflect exactly
what you
want you know there would it's always
best to adopt one amendment but in this
case i think if everybody is is really
clear on what you're doing
um with the
the um
sunset clause and the amendment and
since it's a nice simple amendment with
with one or two pieces
i think we can make it clear and then
what will happen is a single amendment
that you don't have before you will be
created and there will be in the house
calendar you know sort of this go
forward
one amendment that that has
whatever you
all vote on
it contained in it so in the end there
will be one amendment
that is correct doesn't have to be
either of these it could be in a
uh
i think the concept is you would but you
would
potentially adopt both of these
amendments and therefore you would need
a third amendment that combines the two
ideas
and who decides what that third
amendment will contain you have to pass
both of them to make that happen
but we would want to be
extremely clear that everybody agreed on
what that
what you were doing so and i think it
would be clear in this case it would be
the prospective repeal plus it sounds
like 60 days
for the for the remainder of the bill
okay may i just
clarify
my mind which is not at all clear
um
i think that i really do believe that
the relief needs to be soon i don't like
the sunset clause but i do believe that
um
i will vote against my own amendment
in order to provide immediate relief
for those people who need that relief um
i don't know how else to do it because i
like one piece and i don't like the
other piece but i don't want people to
suffer because i'm falling on my
philosophical sword you know you can
withdraw it
i hear but now right now we're talking
the first amendment right now we haven't
taken her amendment up yet okay but i
just i if nothing else i want to show
everybody this is exactly the reason why
i like things being done in subcommittee
so that these issues are sorted out long
before we get to the full committee and
take these things up
and so normally my normal nature would
have been to retain this bill but
because we all have a sense of urgency
um i think
passing upon
upon passage and having us a chance to
have a revisit i think is is a win-win
okay
uh who's next representative herbert
thank you chairman hunt
um
the first amendment is the sunset or the
uh
the initial date the first amendment has
two things in it it has
upon passage
yep and the sunset
that's the amendment that's justin
that's in the first amendment that's the
amount we're discussing
yes
that's the bartlett amendment that you
should have
so uh next up is representative osborne
thank you sorry call coming in at the
same time hey um so i'm probably in the
same boat as my twin representative
ammon over there
but i do think this sunset is a smart
idea
the um
you know the problems that we are seeing
in this particular industry are are
the result of or if not greatly
exacerbated by the pandemic
anytime you have a
exogenous shock to a system like this
people are going to be scrambling to try
to to fill to fill the holes and fulfill
those customers needs um
and uh
i i think we'll find that um you know as
things smooth out as uh
you know delivery drivers become more
experienced as these delivery companies
become more experienced and
providing these services
these kinds of issues are going to
smooth themselves out over time
and this temporary fix that we're
putting in there should
should really only need to be temporary
um
and i think we'll find as time goes on
that having contracts between
the uh
delivery companies and the restaurants
is not
really going to be
the solution that everyone thinks is
going to be
as an example i i do all the customer
service for a
a very large national restaurant chain
we process uh over 10 000 customer
interactions a day
and every single negative interaction we
have is because of the delivery service
that they use
and they do have a contract with them
and it's it's one you have heard of
before
so
um
just again so look look for that in the
future for this problem to be continued
even when contracts are in place
that's really you know it gets to but to
my initial response is that we to force
people to be in a contract a contract to
force businesses to do a contract is is
an anathema to my nature um so
and anyway
uh any more discussion on the motion
to ought to pass on the bartlett
amendment
see none the clerk will call the role
representative petusik
yes representative osborne
yes
representative amman yes representative
abramson
hi
i just realized my video wasn't on
representative ham
yes
representative palma
representative greeson
yes
representative johnson
representative johnson yes sorry
representative terry
yes
representative bartlett
representative abel
yes
representative herbert
representative van haltman
representative fargo
[Music]
yes
17 to 2.
okay mr chair
yes
i would like to
withdraw my amendment
in order to get the best chance of
immediate
relief for
a cause that we all believe in
and to get it to people now while they
need it or at least as close to now as
we
can i don't know if at all if i'm doing
the right thing i
don't like the sunset class i wish it
weren't there but i can't i don't want
to hold things i don't want to hold up
some potential relief if it can be found
so thank you for that please withdraw
um
0.5308
thank you
all right so let's go forward with uh um
motion
um uh
representative hunt second by
representative patousek um ought to pass
as amended
is there any discussion on the motion
is your hand up represent ammon to this
guy
it is
so i just like to say uh get on my
soapbox a little bit here
when we see a
problem in society our first reaction
should not be to create a violation and
a fine for that problem
um i think an intermediary step would be
to allow for more information to flow
into the marketplace so that people can
make better decisions so for instance
if you're a restaurant serving take out
you can't tell who comes in
as a customer or who comes in as a door
dash driver so
one idea would be to make them wear some
kind of identifying mark
so the costs of the restaurant would be
able to decide whether or not to serve
that person or serve that company
and then require
notification on websites right
um
this bill creates a violation
a hundred dollar fine for each violation
without an agreement
and there's no discussion of enforcement
very little i i don't remember
much discussion about enforcement what
happened how do you prove
uh that the client
or you know the customer received the
the end customer receiving the sandwich
or the burrito or whatever it is
how do they
report a violation or even know there is
a violation to report so i think this is
a knee-jerk reaction to a real problem
um
and this type of reaction happens way
too often in the legislature so i'm
going to be voting against all to pass
with the amendment and
those are my reasons so thank you
fair enough um
obviously that's
why i was urging for the sunset is so we
can revisit all these pieces
representative below
thank you mr chair um i just want to
remind people that um one of the
individuals that testified
was tom boucher
who owned several restaurants the
t-bones and cactus cactus jacks and he
was in support of this bill he has over
a thousand employees so there definitely
is an issue he did take enforcement
because he's he did hire an attorney
because this was happening uh to him and
he won because he was able to afford an
attorney so um you know i'm going to go
with this bill i'm going to vote to look
odd to pass because it's much needed
thank you
you're not
is any more discussion on the motion
about to pass as amended
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
representative osborne's hands up i
don't know if that was from before uh
yeah it's from b4
okay uh ought to pass as amended
representative patusik
with gratitude
to representative van halen i vote yes
representative osborne
um the half-hearted
representative ammon no
representative abrams
uh
uh alva eye
representative ham
yes
representative de palma yes
representative greeson
yes
representative johnson
reluctantly yes
representative terry
yes
representative bartlett yes
representative abel
yes
representative herbert
uh yeah they should be in jail for
taking somebody's copyright
representative van halten
yes
representative fargo yes
representative weston
yes
representative bill you
representative burroughs
yes representative mcaleer
yes
and representative hunts
hunt is yes
hunts is
ketchup i just i over pronounce the t i
think
so the vote is 18 to me
18 to you
would it be a minority report
representative
uh if i had more time i would but i'm
going to let this one slide okay
uh do you want to leave it on the
regular calendar rather than
uh putting it
uh
yeah i think let's do that that'll be a
good compromise okay
all right
and we got one bill left and
how much time do we have
a half hour hour
neato's rig how long does it take you to
get to get your vaccine
um i've already figured that in
i don't have to be there all three
fifteen so if i
sign up for three get in my car i'm good
all right i was sure sorry forgot it was
your team right okay
uh so the last bill house bill 618 poly
stream packaging
representative abramson seconded by
representative patusek moves in
expedient to legislate and
representative abramson is recognized to
speak to his motion
uh so here's
the reason that i um
decided to move and expedient to
legislate um the bill on the surface
says it would ban polystyrene but it
doesn't ban the replacement when you
have a container of eggs if they can't
use polystyrene they use plastic or
paper or cardboard
when you're
serving food or have seconds or get
something at the deli or the the soup
kitchen
instead of using if you're not using
polystyrene you're using thick
uh plastic which may not even be
recyclable
uh when you have a to-go box from the
restaurant um to get the same insulating
effect you need a lot of cardboard and
it costs it doesn't just cost a lot more
it's a lot more material or for for a
cup at the coffee shop it's not just the
plastic lid and the thick paper cup the
cardboard sleeve
the black and green ink that they
you invariably use with paper and
cardboard uh which is is toxic when it
ends up in landfills and then leeches
out
um
i
i i viewed this as an either ore and
although i'm not a i'm not a big fan of
polystyrene in general it's
you know it's either this or every other
type of material that gets used and
there's a lot of there's obviously a lot
of polystyrene that's that's in
inventory
that instead of uh you know sitting
around in uh closets and cupboards and
instead of
just disappearing or evaporating it
would have to go out to other states
um because you couldn't use it anymore
uh so i
i understand what the with the uh bill
sponsor is trying to get to she's
concerned about uh uh the landfills
filling up but if you replace these very
useful polystyrene containers with
something else usually end up requiring
heavier or additional material with
something else it doesn't just cost more
to use these alternatives
it's more material and most of the
alternative materials uh using
polystyrene containers almost never have
inks or dyes it and it's those types of
toxic toxic green ink that i was most
concerned about that's why i decided uh
to itl for not just cost but
environmental reasons
okay uh first up is representative
herbert
thank you chairman hunt i am
i'm gonna support
6 18
because we're drowning in this crap and
we have to get rid of it we're going to
have to stop using a lot of things
this being just one
so i mean we don't have a choice in the
matter we're going to have to do it so i
think it's a time to long past time to
uh
we passed the threshold a long time ago
we've got some deep digging to do
and i want to start it as soon as
possible
okay uh representative greeson
sorry i was expecting to be called a
little bit later down the line there
uh thank you mr chairman uh i i'm i'm
actually in in uh in favor of uh of
itling this spill i don't think we need
to actually ban
uh polystyrene containers it's not just
the to go containers polystyrene is used
in all kinds of of applications go to
your meat market or your grocery store
and buy meat and you'll find a a little
plastic a styrofoam tray
and that is proven to be a very
effective means you'd be getting rid of
that what are you going to put the food
on now but even more importantly than
that
i think science is actually presenting a
solution to all the landfill and all the
all the issues for uh
for polystyrene and plastics and stuff
like that
in what mit
is uh has been studying in the effect of
light uh on on polystyrene and plastics
i think there is a machine that somebody
a brilliant mind at mit is is is
prepared to invent that will just
bombard plastic since polystyrene uh
with with the uv and the and the visible
light and break it down right now the
science is saying if you just leave it
out in nature it might take a hundred
years as opposed to a thousand years
great that's great put it in a machine
and bombard it it might only take a day
and a half i don't know what what it is
but certainly there is a a brilliant
mind who's ready to use
and develop a machine that will take
care of that i think science gave us the
polystyrene container and science will
solve the problem
uh represent bilo
thank you mr chair um
representative greeson just
mentioned
meat counters and how the meat is um
sold um
on this phone and in europe they have
adopted alternative um
ways of doing business regarding uh
these styrofoam products
is they bring their own recycled
containers to the meat counters
and to the restaurants so that they can
take home
um their meat or their chico's in their
own recycled containers
thank you
reusable containers
perfect
uh okay representative bartlett
thank you mr chair
well i'd like to address a couple of
things
one is uh regarding inventory this pilot
siren containers take up a lot of room
and this bill would not even be
effective until january the first
so there's plenty of time to get rid of
any inventory that might be there
another issue was that um
there was concern about
these trays being used for meats and
fish and things those are exempted in
the bill there's a number of exemptions
on page
two
that talks about things that would
continue to be used for the time being
um
three
i think that we really have got to
address plastics there are a lot of
different kinds of plastics
um
these polystyrene
um containers i'm i'm certainly hoping
that they will be broken down at some
point but right now the half light on
them half-life on them is very long
and
they're getting involved they they break
down when they break down they the
wildlife
ingest it we
can also ingest it these plastics are
not good
and
for many many years we did not have to
use polystyrene
it's full of fossil based fuels and we
my feeling is that we have got to start
moving away from them and this bill
is a start it's only a start there's
plenty of polystyrene that would
continue to be used
but
alternatives would would start to be
offered
so i cannot um i certainly would
be looking for the motion of otp
okay representative
thank you very much i'd just like to
point out um
a major reason why i would be interested
in an otp motion should one come uh to
the table
is uh is in the bill itself this is
simply enabling legislation the bill
itself and i'm reading from the bill
municipalities shall have the sole
authority under this subdivision to
regulate implement and enforce the
prohibition on polystyrene foam food
service products we are allowing the
municipalities the ability to govern
themselves to decide what works best for
them in terms of this issue perhaps a
very small town
we'll look at this very differently
perhaps their use is very minimal
compared to say a manchester which is
where i reside so i think it's important
to realize that we are not actually
doing anything for polystyrene per se we
are allowing localities to make their
own decisions thank you
okay uh represent patusik
uh thank you mr chair
uh if memory serves
a couple of sessions ago there was a law
something like this against plastic bags
and we know what happens to plastic bags
when covered 19 hit you could not use
any recyclable bags so
i would say in this case be careful of
what you asked for
also a second thing i heard that they
are allowing
people to bring in
their own styrofoam recyclable
things in europe to be reused that has
the same sanitary problems as recyclable
growlers
in the united states as the bill that we
didn't pass
and lastly
i'm concerned about our small businesses
having to pay
twice or three times the amount of what
they're paying now
and still being in the hole
trying to get out of the hole through
the pandemic
thing that we're in until the end of the
year
they can't afford to be buying
new
items to replace polystyrene which is
dirt cheap right now and still try to
make a profit
thank you mr chair
okay so i wouldn't remind everybody this
not to confuse the two words recyclable
and reusable
there are two different concepts
okay so i see himself but i i think
you've all spoken already to do people
want to speak again as representative
bartlett would like to speak thank you
mr chair um yes i just wanted to um
point out that during the pandemic
the new hampshire grocers association
was very
shall we say
forceful
in their
promotion that only new plastic bags
could be used and people couldn't use
bags there had no there was no
scientific
basis from which they were doing that
they were serving their own ends on that
um obviously the
there there's very little scientific
basis for any
contact spread of this virus and we've
those of us that
do
reuse have gone back to our own cloth
bags
that's all
okay uh representative herbert did you
want to speak again
no okay uh representative abramson you
have the last word
um
so i don't know if this committee last
session got any of the plastic bag bands
plastic straw bands and so forth but my
committee certainly got
quite a few of them and we were warned
as i think it was in february right
before the coronavirus
was making its way we received a number
of warnings not just from
uh business groups but also from
um uh private citizens and policy
experts that diseases could spread very
easily through
recycling and if
if recycled bags are made mandatory and
disposable single-use bags were banned
that there would be no flexibility
available and so it ended up being lucky
that the governor vetoed a number of
these bills
just in just the nick of time in some
cases
so my
my preference is let the marketplace
work let individual consumers decide for
themselves
if they're if somebody is morally
opposed to
polystyrene and they just insist on
using cardboard let you know let them go
to a place with recycled cardboard or or
recycled plastic or
some other material
it's much more effective in in my
experience like consumers
uh bring about the change
and um i certainly mcdonald's got the
message and i don't get big macs in
styrofoam anymore i get it in cardboard
okay uh is the question is inexpedient
to legislate question clear
the clerk will call the role
representative patusik
yes
representative osborne
representative ammon yes representative
abramson aye
representative hand
yes representative palmer
yes
representative greeson
representative johnson
yes
representative terry
representative bartlett no
representative abel
no
representative herbert
representative van halen
no
representative fargo
representative weston
no
representative bill you no
representative burrows
no
representative mackel here no
yes
10 to 9.
okay
and i yes there will be a minority
report
and a floor speech how's that
okay yeah uh
uh
yes go ahead jane did you have something
thank you mr chair um could i um just
make a statement about the cdc bears
program i did a little bit of research
without when i was at lunch
my preference would be that yeah i would
love to hear what you have to say and
what you're you know what you're
thinking but um i i would love you just
to send an email out to all the members
okay
okay because
taking action
keeps um from getting on the video
right
question i mean that i mean there's a
problem with what he said
i again i we this is going to be an
ongoing discussion i'm sure and i and i
i'm very interested in hearing it um
obviously we retained it so we can talk
about it a lots and lots come september
but um but i feel free to send that an
email to forward as a response
um
i want to remind everybody that those
who did make the motions i'd like to
have
um your uh majority and minority reports
um you know by you know by thursday um
we've got extra day here so tomorrow
afternoon where you would have been
doing this
please get in front of your computer and
pound out uh some
some short stories for me um can i just
ask um of the dems does
um somebody want to do the minority
report on the styrofoams or do you want
me to do it that was my question who's
doing representative burroughs just put
up your hands
representative burrows you're going to
do the um minority report on this one i
would be delighted okay
okay yes and not to pass okay so then um
uh
just in terms of the floor session
obviously um you know if people want to
speak and i'll be working with you
chrissy but obviously we want to um we
want to kind of keep the speakers list
down uh we want to be have the
reputation as a committee that that
short brief and to point and uh without
belaboring and putting everybody to
sleep um and and just dragging this
painful sessions
i don't think anybody's sleeping during
this session
so uh that's probably true but um i
don't know it just feels like a nice
carpet there you know i feel very good
just rolling soccer
lie down and go to sleep um so otherwise
this is i'm pleased that we were able to
get a comp get this done uh uh as
quickly as we have and accomplish it i
realized that it it looks uh very
foreboding when we get to september and
october um so i would warn everybody
that normally we only did one day a week
and we would have um you know uh
subcommittees working
uh
simultaneously and i would still be
doing that anyway simultaneously
but i think that we can still uh work uh
very efficiently and try to and get
through all these um a lot of them will
be depend upon what happens with the
senate and so this is this is just
we're only in we're only at intermission
for committee work
um and we will take this up again uh in
in april i want to remind everybody
again about the the vacation that i will
be taking so that means you get a
vacation and that would be the uh i fly
out the 9th april 9th so there must be
10 12 april 12 12 through the 17th at
five days um that the commerce will not
be be doing anything uh
i'm sorry what
i'm going off the top my head to the
calendar but i assume it's the 12th
to the 17th that that's set monday to
monday to uh
12th to the 17th we're not meeting p
period right no meeting
okay
so yeah 12 to this yeah six don't get
sunburned
uh right
so are we not meeting tomorrow
so we are not we don't need to meet
tomorrow so we roll off so do your do
your minority report
um and
anything else i need to say thank you
all very much and uh
um just let the dems know that i will be
sending out an email this afternoon and
um we'll we'll do a caucus in the next
day john
yes do we send the minority and majority
reports to you and
carrie well you can't but she's gonna
then forward it to me so you know i'm
sending it to me and then i and then i
review that and then i send him on to
carrie and then carrie posts them and
then pam gets one more look at it
terrible stuff um and i'm and i you know
i don't change people's minority reports
too badly
but other than that uh i'll have a
wonderful cold day and hopefully an
expectation of warm weather
soon enough
so
we're out of exact
bye-bye
bye